This is Jocko podcast number 54 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Uneasy lies the head that wears the crown.
You got some Shakespeare right there,
got some Henry,
the fourth part two and that play is a play that came just prior to Henry the
fifth,
the hero.
The warrior.
Okay.
The leader of that few,
that happy few,
that band of brothers.
Well,
his dad,
Henry,
the fourth was having a rough time in the kingdom facing rebellion and there's a
point in the play where he,
the old man had been the fourth,
he can't sleep,
can't sleep because the pressure,
the pressure and the weight of being a leader and it's a great,
it's a great joke of the play and it starts with that line.
Uneasy lies the head that wears the crown.
It,
it actually doesn't start with that line.
That's the last line.
It starts off a little different.
It starts off here.
How many thousand of my poorest subjects are at this hour asleep.
So he's saying,
hey,
out there,
you know,
there's thousands and thousands of my subjects.
They're out there sleeping right now.
Oh,
sleep,
oh,
gentle sleep,
natures soft nurse.
How have I frightened me that thou will watch that thou no more will weigh my
eyelids down and steep my senses in forgetfulness.
So he's talking to sleep.
Sleep is like a,
like a god to him at this point.
And he said,
what did I do to scare you off what I do?
How come you won't bring me that goodness way down my eyes
going back.
Why rather sleep liased vow in smokey cribs upon uneasy pallets,
stretching v and hushed with buzzing night flies to the ice slumber.
Then in perfumed chambers of the great onto the canopies of costly state and
load with sound of sweetest melody.
So he's asking sleep,
he's saying,
look,
sleep.
You're there.
You're there out in the smoky fill fee,
houses in all levels and people are sleeping on boards and,
and uh,
too low people asleep in those situations.
It's insects buzzing around their heads.
You sleeps all,
they're taking care of those people.
But sleep doesn't come to him.
And the most beautiful in the most luxurious est rooms where there's,
where there's little gentle music playing,
no bugs flying around.
It's a little gentle music play
back to the play.
Oh Thou [inaudible] God.
Why liased vow with the vial in loans,
some beds and [inaudible] fight king leak couch or watch case or a common larame
bell.
So same,
same subject.
He's saying,
look,
why do you Dole God?
So Dole meaning sleeping doll.
Why are you hanging around the nastiest beds?
But you,
you know this beautiful bed,
don't come near it.
You leave it vacant like a,
like a watch tower,
like a bell tower.
Wilt Thou upon the high and Giddy mast,
seal up the ship.
Boy's eyes.
So now he's talking and start talking about even a sailor at sea high up on a
mast,
right?
A giddy mast.
You seal up the ship,
boys eyes and rock his brains in cradle of the rude imperious search.
And in the visitation of wins who take the rough,
Ian billows by the top curling their monstrous heads and hanging them with
deafening clamor in the slippery clouds that with the early death itself awakes.
Okay,
so he's saying this sailor,
there's a sailor at sea who's getting punished by this storm and the,
the thunder is clapping and there's the ship is bounding back and forth.
But guess what?
He gets to fall asleep.
He goes to sleep,
no problem.
Canst thou o partial sleep,
give die repos to the web.
See Boy in an hour.
So rude and in the calmest and most stillest night with all appliances and means
to boot,
deny it to a kink.
So he's saying again in an hour.
So root storms may him at sea,
he gives the,
he gives the sailor sleep,
but in this columnist and still list night with every available luxury to boot,
yet sleep is denied to the game.
And then he says,
then happy low lie down.
Uneasy lies the head that wears the crown.
So then happy low lie down.
He's saying look low by low,
he means the peasants.
He's like,
all right,
then you happy,
happy Lo you peasants lie down,
lie down to sleep.
That's what you,
that's what you get.
But uneasy lies the head that wears the crown.
The leader doesn't get to rest,
the leader doesn't get to sleep.
And that's another example of what we know when that is that leadership is hard.
It's a heavy burden,
it's hard business and it's part science and part art
and part of it is natural ability and part of it is learned.
And the book that we're going to dive into today,
it isn't Shakespeare,
it's actually a military manual,
military manual written by SLA Marshall,
but guided by George General,
George C.
Marshall and Dwight d Eisenhower.
And this book was written just after World War II.
Now if you remember Hackworth,
if you've read about face Hackworth,
talks about Marshall Sla,
Marshall and any,
he did some writing in Vietnam that Hackworth was a little bit not impressed
with.
And there's certainly some controversy about SLA Marshall and some of the things
that he wrote.
And some of the things that he said that he lived through.
There's some controversy if not proven fact that he fabricated some stuff,
but I think you're gonna find as we dive into this book that from a leadership
perspective,
the experiences that he did bring back from World War One,
the experiences that he got from Eisenhower and from the other Marshall.
I think it's a really good reflection and a and a good look at some leadership
lessons learned that we can take something from now.
The book is actually called the Armed Forces officer.
Very simple title and the the,
the version that I'm going through because this book is still in publication,
the version that I'm going through is a 19 is from 1950 1950 version.
Like I said,
it's written and we'll just after world war two obviously,
so the lessons are fresh and I guess that the new version has been cleaned up or
something.
There's,
there's,
I guess that the 1950s version isn't fully politically,
I don't know because to be frank,
I haven't read the new version because I got the old version.
I want the real deal and I don't find anything offensive in this,
in this one.
So maybe someone else will,
I guess there's some things that might be a little bit borderline,
but yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not really feeling it in this book was given to me a long time ago by a
friend of mine that said,
you might like this,
and he specifically said this,
but they'll make this one anymore.
But guess what?
Everyone's in love because they do.
They brought it back,
they brought it back.
So the book is the Armed Forces officer and it really goes into how to lead,
how to lead.
So going to the book to call forth great loyalty and other people and to harness
it to any noble undertaking,
one must first be sensible of their finder instincts and feelings.
Certainly these things at least are among the gentle qualities which are desired
in every military officer of the United States.
So here's some basic things that the officers in the military are supposed to
have.
One strong belief in human rights to respect for the dignity of every other
person.
Three,
the golden rule attitude toward one's daily associates for an abiding interest
in all aspects of human welfare.
Five,
a willingness to deal with every man as considerately as if he were a blood
relative.
It's a pretty simple rules.
Respect other people.
The golden rule,
you know,
treat people how you want to be treated yourself.
That's,
these are the basis of what they're saying you need to be,
and again,
less not actually I'm not.
I was going to go into this,
but they're going to go into it themselves.
Here we go.
Back to the book.
These qualities are the epitome of strength,
not of softness.
They mark the man who's capable of pursuing a great purpose consistently in
spite of temptations.
He who possesses them,
we'll all the more surely be regarded as a man among men.
Take any crowd of new recruits,
the greater number of them during their first few days in service,
we'll use more profanity and obscenity,
talk more about women and boasts more about drinking than they have ever done in
their lives because of the mistaken idea that this is the quick way to get a
reputation for being hard boiled,
but at the same time,
the one or two men among them who stayed decent talk moderately and walk the
line of duty will uniquely receive the infinite respect of the others.
Okay.
It never fails to happen.
Yeah,
so little contrary to what we might think,
and there's definitely,
when you get in the military,
when you're going through bootcamp,
there's all kinds of people acting like tough guys.
All kinds of people act like tough guys and that that happens is you.
One thing that happens in bootcamp,
I s I bet I met more potential professional athletes when I was going through,
when I was going through bootcamp,
everyone was,
I was about to go in the NFL.
I was about to be a pro baseball player.
I don't know why,
but they ended up in the military.
Interesting.
Yeah,
it is interesting that kind of like the guy who's 500.0 in the streets,
it comes to the MMA gym.
That guy,
that guy doesn't work out too well.
All right,
and obviously I'm a bridging this book a little bit skipping through here we go
back to the book,
men be get goodwill in other men by giving it,
they develop courage in their following mainly as a reflection of the courage
which they show in their own action.
These two qualities of mind and heart are the essence of sound officer ship.
One is of little avail without the other and either helps to sustain the other.
So you got goodwill and you've got courage and they help each other and they
sustain each other back to the book as to which is the stronger force in its
impact upon the masses of men.
No truth is more certain than the words.
Once written by William James.
Evident though the shortcomings of a man may be if he is ready to give up his
life for a cause.
We forgive him everything,
however inferior he may be to ourselves and other respects.
If we cling to life while he throws it away like a flower,
we bow to his superiority.
So I guess courage gets the stronger nod out of that situation.
Back to the book,
Theodore Roosevelt once said,
if he had a son who refrained from any worthwhile action because of the fear of
hurt to himself,
he would disown him
soon after his return to civilian life.
General Dwight d Eisenhower spoke of the ward,
the worthwhileness of living dangerously and officer of the United States.
Armed Forces cannot go far wrong if he holds these ideas.
It is not the suitable profession for those who believe.
Only in digging in and nursing a soft snap until death comes at a ripe old age
who risks nothing,
gains nothing,
nor should there be any room in it for professional smugness,
small jealousies,
and undue concern about privilege.
So
you can't be hiding all the time.
You got to step up.
You gotta lead.
You gotta take some risks.
You got to live dangerously.
Now,
of course,
young troopers out there,
specially guys out on the battlefield.
This doesn't mean running to your death.
It was what it means.
You will take risk in business world.
You'll take risk in the military.
You'll take risk if you do either in business or in the military,
you take risk.
Stupidly you'll die or you'll lose all your money.
Neither one of those is good,
but
that doesn't mean you hide and it doesn't mean you take no risk and you shy
away.
Now the next part,
when he's talking about small jealousies and undue concern about privilege,
this eats people up and destroys people in that light.
Here we go back to the book towards services other than his own.
Any officer is expected to have both a comradery feeling and an imaginative
interest.
Any army officer is a better man for having studied the works of Admiral Mayhem
and familiarize himself with the modern navy from firsthand experience.
Those who lead.
See going forces can enlarge their own capacities by knowing more rather than
less about the nature of the air and ground establishments.
The sub mariner can always learn something useful to his own work.
By mingling with airmen,
the airman becomes a better officer as he grows and qualified knowledge of
ground and see fighting.
So you got to learn working with other industries.
Learn about those industries.
Learn as much as you can.
Don't just stay in your own little in your own little world cause you're
comfortable.
I said,
what happens to a lot of us?
You get comfortable in your own world.
So that's what you want to stay in.
You don't want to look bad,
you don't appear to be ignorant.
And animal man is kind of the,
well he was a civil war animal as a matter of fact,
but wrote,
wrote a book called the influence of Sea power upon history,
which the Germans and the Japanese both utilized against us in World War Two.
So a little bit of a little bit of risk there,
but it is also something that guided the thought and the building of the,
of the modern us navy.
Now we talk a little bit about what life is like in the military.
Back to the book.
The military way is a long,
hard road and it makes extraordinary requirements of every individual in war
particularly.
It puts stresses upon men such as they have not known elsewhere.
And the temptation to get out from under would be irresistible if their spirits
had not been tempered to the ordeal.
So you gotta be ready for the hardest.
You've got to do things in your life that get you ready for the hardness back to
the book,
if nothing but fear.
And this is now we're getting to some leadership if nothing but fear of
punishments were dependent upon to hold men to the line during extreme trial.
The result would be wholesale mutiny and the situation all together beyond the
control of leadership.
So if the only thing,
the only reason that your people are falling you,
cause if it's because of fear of punishment,
when the going gets hard,
that's not gonna work.
Hmm.
So it must be true that it is the out that is out of the impact of ideals out of
the impact of ideals,
mainly that men develop the strength to face situations which would be normal to
run away,
which it would be normal to run away.
Also during the normal routine of peace,
members of the armed services are expected to respond to situations that are
more extensive,
more complex,
and take longer to reach fulfillment than the situations to which the majority
of men instinctively respond.
So things in the military to take a long time.
When you're a big part of that in the peacetime big bureaucratic machine,
it can be really challenging.
Even the length of the enlistment period looks like a slow march up.
A 60 mile grade promotion is slow duty,
frequently monotonous.
It is all too easy for the individual to worry about his own insignificance and
to feel that he has become lost in the crowd.
Now,
this is something that I hear a lot about on social media.
More people send me messages on this or or Facebook messages I guess.
Um,
when they feel like they're kind of caught in a Rut,
you know,
they're doing their job,
they don't really like it.
What should I do?
And I think this next little section applies to that.
Back to the book,
what is the main test of human character?
Okay.
Probably it is this,
that a man will know how to be patient in the midst of hard circumstance and can
continue to be personally effective while living through whatever
discouragements beset him and his companions.
Can you drive on?
That's what it's asking those,
that job that you don't like.
Good.
It's a little test now if you're in a situation that you don't like,
you drive on and that situation and also you figured out what your exit strategy
is going to be cause you don't want to go through life miserable.
Yeah.
You figure out,
you start saving your money,
you start getting another education,
you figure it out on the job.
You get yourself promoted,
you do what you gotta do,
but don't let that monotonous job that's you're not into that day.
Don't let that bird you down.
Yeah.
That's kind of the key there were you'd drive on and it's like you drive on in
life.
You don't necessarily have to drive on and keep doing that job.
It's like you drive on as opposed to ou start complaining or go into some thing
where you get self destructive,
where you seek,
seek some kind of,
I don't know,
escapist outlet or something like that,
but I'll tell you,
you do,
you drive on it.
You have other options,
right?
You work those other options,
but whatever it is that your job is,
and you'd kick ass at that job.
Yeah.
That's what you do it.
The minute you start slacking,
you're going backwards.
Don't do it.
It's not going to what?
What benefit are you gonna get from that?
You're going to get zero benefit.
You're going to work your eight hours a day,
you're going to make your $12 an hour.
Are you going to do it in a slack way?
Yeah.
Or are you getting,
are you going to do it in an awesome way?
I keep,
you know how I'm going to do in an awesome way.
Yeah.
And that's what's going to get you promoted.
That's what's going to get you,
that's what's going to get you taken care of in the long run.
If you or you,
you like you say this a lot,
where you,
even if you're going to do something,
even if you don't enjoy,
you still,
you do it just the best you can.
I think you said that like from the beginning and for someone like me,
when I look at it like that,
um,
of course it sounds like a good idea to do it that way,
but after you do it,
you kind of think back and I've done both.
I've done it where I'm like,
oh,
I hate doing this,
so I'm just going to basically go through the motions until it's finally done,
you know?
And I can kind of be relieved or whatever.
But when you think back of like,
Hey,
I remember when I was doing whatever it is,
that job or whatever.
When you look back,
you kind of have this fulfillment that you did it the best you can.
You know,
you never look back and be like,
Dang,
I'm glad I've phoned it in.
You know you always are going to,
even if he didn't like it like you,
you're always satisfied that that yeah,
I did it the best that I could.
So do it,
do it the best you can.
Now
here's a,
there's a couple of the lists in this book.
Here's another one.
This is the one that's talking about the the simple virtues that provide a firm
foundation.
So here we go.
One a man has honor if he holds himself to a course of conduct because of a
conviction that it is in the general interest,
even though he is a well aware that it may lead to inconvenience,
personal loss,
humiliation or grave physical at risk.
So when he says general interest,
he's talking about like the team.
So you're going to hold that conviction.
Even if it's good for the team,
you're going to hold that course even if you're well aware that it may lead to
inconvenience,
personal loss,
humiliation or grave physical risk.
Boom.
That's what honor is.
You know here,
honored,
laid out that well,
very often he has veracity.
If having studied a question to the limit of his ability,
he says and believes what he thinks to be true,
even though it would be the path of least resistance to deceive others and
himself.
So this is kind of in the same vein.
If you,
if you look at something and maybe you don't agree with it,
but the easiest thing to do would just be agree with it.
No,
you don't do that.
You step up and say,
Hey,
no,
I don't agree with this.
Now,
we could go into detail on that in the times when you,
when you do want to maybe not be the most truthful person in the world.
For instance,
we've talked about this before,
when your wife is making chicken and it's dry,
right?
It might not be the best thing to tell her the the amount of water that you're
going to need to drink.
So,
but in real things and important things.
Tell the truth.
Back to the book.
Number three he has justice.
He acknowledges the interest of all concerned in any particular transaction
rather than serving his own apparent interest.
Look out for others.
Number four,
he has graciousness if he acts and speaks forthrightly,
agrees,
warmly,
disagrees fairly and respectfully participates enthusiastically refrains from
harboring grudges,
takes his reverses in stride and does not complain or ask for help in the face
of trifling calamities.
Those are just solid.
I would say this though,
sometimes you got to ask for help,
right?
That's one thing that I want to work with businesses.
There'll be somebody that's extreme ownership and I'm going to own this and all
of a sudden you realize that,
hey,
you're owning that,
but if you're not going to be successful at it because that's too much for you,
you need help.
You need to,
you need to put your ego in check and you need to be able to raise your hand and
say,
look,
I need some help on this.
I can't,
I don't have this cupboard.
This is too much for me.
I want to expect in this,
here's my hands in the air.
Let me get,
let me get some help sometimes.
Seems like it's not necessarily even ego.
It's more like,
oh,
I guess in a way it's ego,
but it's more like,
shoot,
I don't want to be the guy who has to be dependent on somebody or something like
that.
Like I,
you know,
which is what extreme ownership,
which is ego.
Actually.
If you're the guy that doesn't want to be dependent on other people,
that's probably regal,
but you are.
I think what you're trying to say is that I don't want to be the guy that has to
ask for help.
I want to be that guy cares my own load.
I'd see this on on seal patrols and a couple of times in my career where guys
were overloaded and they didn't want to ask for help.
I got this because it's humiliating,
you know,
hey,
can you carry my ammunition?
Or Hey,
can you carry my radio?
Yeah.
Can you carry my weapon?
That's I,
I've,
I've seen it happen.
I've carried some extra weapons from time to time and it's,
it's a bummer,
you know,
and you know what?
Take the weapon I.
Amen.
Okay.
Get some water in you.
You know,
but that's what you're talking about.
People don't want to be that guy,
but what's going to be worse if they don't take a load off and they get a heat
casualty and now they're down.
Well now we're,
now I've got to carry him not just as a weapon,
which is a bad thing.
We don't have them anymore.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And he can't,
he can't fight.
He can't even do anything as opposed to the other guy who doesn't know the
difference between needing help and wanting help.
Oh,
help me.
Cause you don't want to work.
I had a guy one time,
we were on a long patrol.
This is back in the day.
Back in the day,
this is prewar and my radio man,
because I was a rating then when I was enlisted guy and now I wasn't ready to
Manaus and officer and,
and we were on a long patrol and my radio man was going down like he was,
didn't have enough water,
was dehydrated,
it was weak.
And so he was bummed,
you know,
he's,
he,
he couldn't keep up with us anymore.
And I said,
okay,
let me get your radio.
So I'm taking a 20 pound radio off his back,
putting in my back.
I'm carrying it for a little,
I don't know,
the half a day.
And then we get to a,
like a layup point.
So this is where we're going to see for civilian of this is we're going to camp
out for the night and when we get there we get a resupply of water and Gatorade
or whatever.
So all of a sudden now everyone's rehydrated and while we're in there,
we got to make a communication a hit too.
You've got to call headquarters and say,
Hey,
this is our location.
So he comes in and takes the radio out of my,
out of my backpack,
you know,
it comes over,
hey link at the radio so I can make this communication.
It's like,
oh yeah,
cool.
Open up my bag,
give it to him.
And you know,
he makes the radio communications and I'm out doing like a reconnaissance of the
area to find out what route we're going to take.
Anyways,
I thought,
you know,
now he's rehydrated decent,
take that radio and you know,
we'll be back in back in the game.
So I come back and when I get back the radio was sitting on my rucksack.
Oh No.
But you know what?
I did put it back in my rucksack carried out.
Yeah.
You've just got to do it.
Um,
but yeah,
so you don't want to be that guy once you get rehydrated man,
get your weight back on
the difference between needing help in one.
Yeah.
And he did need help.
At one point.
But once the Gatorades come in,
you know,
you're good to go take that radio back.
I was,
uh,
chuckling inside when I saw that radio.
Been placed back on top of my run.
Not Inside,
but just placed on you.
You got it from here.
Yeah,
you got to put it back in and thanks and we'll be all good.
Awesome,
good times.
And the last one here,
he has integrity.
If his interest in the good of the service is at all times greater than his
personal pride.
And when he holds himself to the same line of duty,
when unobserved as he would follow if all his superiors were present,
this is the classic,
what do you do when you're not,
when people aren't looking,
you know,
here's another point.
The cause of much of the friction,
it administrative machinery is that at all levels there are individuals who
insist on standing in their own light and now this is a term to actually had to
look upstanding.
You're only,
it means getting your own way.
It means you're,
you're,
you're preventing your,
you're preventing your own success and he uses the term of lunch in here
standing in your own life.
This is important.
They believe that there is some special magic,
some quick springboard to success.
They mistakenly think that it can be won by boot licking,
apple polishing,
yessing higher authority playing office politics,
weight around,
ducking the issue,
striving for cheap popularity,
courting publicity,
or seeking any and all means of grabbing the spotlight.
So this is the guy,
everybody that's listening to this podcast right now knows that who I'm talking
about,
that guy,
that guy that's just always trying to kiss everyone's ass and make himself look
good and,
and that's,
you know,
that's a shortcut,
right?
This is what Marshall St is a is a shortcut or a springboard.
You think it's a quick springboard
back to the book.
Any one of this set of tricks may enable a man to carry the ball forward,
a yard or two in some special situation.
But at least this comment can be made without qualification of the men who have
risen to supreme heights and the fighting establishment of the United States and
have had their greatness proclaimed by their fellow countrymen.
There is not one career which provides any warrant for the conclusion that there
is a special shortcut known only to the smart operators.
True enough,
a few men have gained fairly high ranked by dint of what late Mr. Justice Holmes
called the instinct for the juggler,
a feeling of when to jump and where to press and how to slash in order to
achieve somewhat predatory personal ends
that will occasionally happen in any walk of life.
And I say this all the time,
I've said this on this podcast,
if you got that guy that we're talking about,
sometimes they're gonna if they're going to get a better recommendation you,
but sometimes they're going to get,
they're going to get that promotion that you were wanting and you,
you just,
you just held the line and we're a good person.
That person took the credit for something and no one really realized.
And next thing you know,
they get the promotion.
But I agree with what's being said here.
That does happen sometimes in every walk of life,
but in the long run,
that person's going down.
Yeah.
That person's going down in the long run.
And the more you kind of depend on that sort of thing,
the less likely for any kind of success anyway.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Yup.
Okay.
And he says here,
but from Washington,
Wayne and Jones down to Eisenhower,
Vandergriff and Nimitz,
the best,
the men,
best loved by the American people,
for their military successes.
We're also the men with greatness of soul.
Okay.
During World War Two,
there were quite a few higher commanders relieved in our forces because it was
judged for one reason or another that they had failed in battle.
So relieved means you got fired of the total number.
There were a few who took a reduction in rank,
went willingly to a lower post and a fighting command,
utter no complaints,
kept their chins up,
worked courageously and sympathetically with their commands,
and provide an example of manhood that all who saw them,
we'll never forget.
So if you get,
I get asked this,
I've gotten,
been asked this a couple times.
I got demoted or sometimes not demoted,
but I got passed over.
You know,
someone else got promoted instead of me.
What should I do?
Hmm.
Get after it.
That's what these guys did.
Hey,
you screwed up.
You know what?
Check.
All right,
cool.
Let's,
let's say,
here's what I messed up.
That was my fault.
I'm ready to rock and roll.
You put me down,
put me in charge of less people.
I got it.
I'm going to do well though their names need not be mentioned.
They were imprinted with the real virtue of the services even more deeply than
many of their colleagues who had no blemishes on their records.
Their character had met the ultimate test.
The men who had the privilege of working close to them realized this and the
supply,
sublime effect of his personal influence help strengthen the resolve of many
others.
So it's actually inspirational to people around you.
When they see that,
and there's been many guys that I've known that a bounce back for some kind of
form,
some kind of,
you know,
career problem,
they mess something up.
They got,
they got fired and they take it.
They'd be humble about it and they come back and turn it around.
The person that complains and thinks that they're a victim,
not going to work out for him.
That's an in the civilian sector and in the military sector.
Now,
let's start talking to him a little bit about being a recruit and the kind of
the,
the mental training,
the mindset training that happens as a recruit to the book,
his Pr,
his perseverance in the care of weapons in keeping his living quarters orderly
and in doing his full share of work is best insured,
not through fear of punishments but by stimulating his belief that any other way
of going is unworthy of a member of a fighting service.
Precision in personal habits,
precision in drill and precision in daily living are the high road to that kind
of discipline,
which best ensures cool and collected thought and unity of action on the field
of battle.
Yeah.
You know,
it's just the,
it's,
it's basically he's talking about the,
the,
the unmitigated daily discipline in all things.
That's what it is and that ensures cool and collected,
fought and unity of action on the field of battle.
Now I got nothing to say about that other than yes.
Amen.
Here's another little section.
When men are well led,
they become fully receptive to the whole body of ideas which their leaders see
fit to put before them.
Let's think about that.
When men are well led,
they become fully receptive to the whole body of ideas which their leaders see
fit to put before them.
So what we're talking about here is when somebody is a good leader,
the troopers around them,
the people that are working for them,
they start to,
they believe a whole body,
everything,
right?
They start
to believe everything that you're saying.
And that's powerful.
That's obviously powerful.
Yeah.
It kind of goes back to like what you were saying about,
um,
like if you're a,
if they fear your punishment,
that's how you lead,
you know,
iron fist and they fear the punishment.
So they're going to do enough to not get punished,
but they won't do anything that they don't have to.
Yeah.
It's so it's only what they have to do,
so you won't get people doing their best.
You know what I mean?
So,
yeah.
Yeah.
And that,
that,
that punishment piece that I kind of breezed through is,
is not through fear of punishments,
but by stimulating his belief that any other way.
So that's 100% right.
And we've seen,
you know,
I say that all the time.
If you,
if people are doing what you told him to do just because they're afraid of you,
sure you can get get that's going to work for a little while,
right?
You know,
all you,
I'll fire you.
Okay.
What's that person doing?
We gets home putting this,
putting his resume on monster.com looking for another job,
doing the best and not to get fired.
The best not to get fired.
He's,
he's,
yeah.
All right.
Going back to the book though,
it has been said before,
even so it can be said again.
It is paramount and overriding responsibility of every officer to take care of
his men before caring for himself.
Yet many junior officers do not seem to understand that steadfast,
steadfast fidelity to it is required,
not lip service and have this,
as Admiral Mahann would say,
man would say,
comes much evil.
The loyalty of men simply cannot be commanded when they become embittered by
selfish action.
So a minute your troop c that you're being selfish or you're doing this for
yourself,
that's the beginning of well,
we,
he says,
Adam,
a man says much evil.
He says,
evil comes from that.
When you started acting selfishly as a leader,
Hmm.
If an officer is on a tour with an enlisted man,
he takes care of the man.
He takes care of that.
The man is accommodated as to food,
shelter,
medical treatment,
or other prime needs before satisfying his own wants.
If that means that the last meal or the last bed is gone,
his duty is to get along the hard way.
Boom.
Take care of your people.
Now again,
this is written in 1950 but even in 1950 you might think this is a hard post.
World War Two,
Chapter Eight is actually called getting along with people.
Boom.
Now,
here's a real,
and some of this stuff is so simple,
so obvious.
It's so simple and so obvious that they had to write a book about it so that
people could do it cause we all fail to do it.
So here we go.
If you like people,
if you seek contact with them rather than hiding yourself in a corner,
if you study your fellow men sympathetically,
if you try consistently to contribute
to something to this success and happiness or contribute something to their
success and happiness,
if you are reasonably generous,
which your thoughts and your time,
if you have a partial reserve with everyone but as seeming reserve with no one,
if you work to be interesting,
rather than spend to be a good fellow,
you will get along with your superiors,
your subordinates,
your orderly,
your roommate,
and the human race.
That's all you got.
If you want to get along with everybody.
Now,
one of the ones that I,
I,
you know,
these are all pretty obvious,
but one of the ones,
if you have a partial reserve with everyone,
but a seemingly but a seeming reserve with no one.
So what that means is you're not just flying off the handle.
You,
you're just reserved a little bit.
You're just,
you,
she'll restraint.
But the restraint doesn't come across as aloofness,
right?
It's not so much,
you know,
if I come into a room and I'm going to show restraint,
so I'm not going to say hi to you,
I'm going to come across as aloof and you're not going to like me.
But if I,
but if I was walking to go echo my brother,
I'll give me a hug.
Well,
you're not gonna like me,
either
you or one of the few people.
Well,
that's the Hawaiian Aloha spirit.
So,
so it's,
it's that measured reserve,
that measured restraint to balance is a little dichotomy there.
I got to find a good,
good spot in the middle.
Again,
getting along with people back to the book by the scores of thousands precepts
and platitudes have been written for the guidance of personal conduct.
The odd part is that despite all of this labor,
most of the frictions in modern society arise from the individuals feeling of
inferiority,
his false pride,
his vanity,
his unwillingness to yield space to any other man,
unwillingness to yield space to any of them.
And I get hit on this one a lot because again,
because of my personalities can be a little bit forceful.
People think I'm just no compromise my way or the highway and this is what
they're talking about.
I'm not like that.
I'm open to suggestions.
I'm willing to say,
you know what?
That's a better idea.
Or you know what?
I like your idea.
Could we make this adjustment to it or yes,
I can change my idea to fit with what you're saying because it makes sense.
People that don't do that have unwillingness to yield space to any other man
continuing on and his co consequent urge to throw his own weight around.
Right?
These are just ways to not get along with people and speaking of ways to get not
get along with people.
Here's the 13 mistakes,
the 13 mistakes.
This is from the United States Coast Guard magazine.
13 pitfalls.
Here we go.
One to attempt to set up your own personal to attempt to set up your own
standard of right and wrong,
to try to measure the enjoyment of others by your own.
To expect uniformity of opinions in the world,
to fail to make allowance for inexperience.
It's a good one to endeavor to mold all dispositions alike,
not to yield on unimportant trifles same thing we just heard the things that
don't matter.
Who Cares?
Let the guys do what they're going to do on that
to look for perfection in our own actions,
to worry ourselves and others about what can't be remedied.
Why you worried about that?
Can't change it.
Let's not worry about it.
Let's just move on.
Here's a big one,
not to help everybody wherever,
however,
whenever we can.
That's a big ask.
That's a big requests.
Hey,
you know what I want you to do in your life.
Help everybody,
however,
wherever and whenever you can.
That's,
that's asking a lot.
That's a big one
to consider.
Impossible.
What?
We cannot ourselves perform.
Nike.
You'd never do that
to believe only what our finite minds can grasp.
I must say that one again to believe only what our finite minds can grasp.
That's humility to recognize it.
You know what?
I don't understand everything in the world.
It's okay.
There's things beyond my comprehension and that's okay.
You got to admit to that
not to make allowances for the weaknesses of others
to estimate by some outside quality when it is that within,
which makes the man
so
very simple.
Interesting how you can make allowances for or according to the 13 things,
you can make allowances for inexperience of others,
but not the weakness of a know.
It says,
it says not to make,
so this would be a mistake.
It would be a mistake not to make allowances for the weaknesses of others.
All threes.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
You got to just say,
oh,
this,
this guys,
you know,
I got to,
I got to make allowances for flex a little bit,
just a little bit and not fly off the handle.
Yeah.
Back to the book.
It's suffice to say that when any officer has the inexcusable fault that he
takes snap judgment on his own men,
he will not be any different in his relations with all other people and we'll
stand in his own light for the duration of his career.
There's that term.
If you're,
if you're making snap judgments of people,
you're,
you're not going to do him justice.
And that's something that I was always very careful about because I've talked
about before and the seal teams,
you're reputation is very,
very important and everybody that's done something stupid in the seal teams,
every single person knows it.
I mean at a high level of stupidity,
if you,
if you do something really stupid,
everybody knows about it.
And then minor,
stupid things.
A lot of people know about it.
And so you develop a reputation over time and
it's very easy to fall in that category of all,
I heard this guy's,
you know,
kind of a Turd or whatever and not give them a chance.
But I always,
I always tried to give people a chance and say,
okay,
let me see what this guy is really like.
And I guess I would take a little personal challenge if it was a guy that was
going to be working for me.
Let's see if I can make this guy rock and roll.
You know,
let me see if I can make this guy into a solid seal.
Can't always pull it off,
but sometimes you can just need that second chance.
Some people go too far with the mistakes that they made their own.
They don't get a second chance.
Okay.
We've talked about this before.
Let's talk about it again.
Here we go.
The man who will not listen,
never develops wits enough to distinguish between a bore and a sage and
therefore cannot pick the best company.
Okay.
The vacant stare,
the drifting of eyes from the speaker to a window or a picture or a passing
blonde,
though greatly tempting in the midst of long discourse are taken only as signs
of inattention.
Many a young officer called to the carpet for some trivial businesses managed to
square himself with his commander just by looking straight and talking straight
in the few moments that decided his future.
So I guess this might be something that didn't make the politically correct
version.
If your eyes are wandering on a passing belonged that while we're having this
conversation,
so that might've been one of those things where they change that for the 2007 in
addition.
That's show chauvinist.
Yeah,
I guess that would be chauvinist stick.
It's the blonde.
It didn't think girl.
Okay,
well maybe a good point.
Maybe it's maybe it seems like racial anti Brown haired people
and this is important though.
You go into,
it's all,
you're in trouble.
Okay.
You get there,
look straight and talk straight for a few minutes with the boss.
Hey,
this boss is what happened.
This is what I did.
This some mistakes I made.
That's got infinitely better chance of of you recovering from that situation as
when you go in there and their bumped to buy,
buy,
buy.
But don't be that guy.
Don't be that guy
elsewhere in the book,
a great deal has been said about the importance of the voice and of developing
one's powers of conversation.
Not a great deal needs to be added there,
but there is no excuse for the officer who talks so that others must strain to
hear what he's saying.
Unless he is suffering from laryngitis.
It is simple enough to keep the chin up and let the words rollout.
Many persons have the bad habit of letting the voice drop at the end of a
sentence.
The effect on the other party is like watching a man run away from a fight.
Notice I said fight really loud because I didn't want to be the guy that was
dropping off on the end of a sentence.
So you're just talking about speaking and how you speak and speaking clearly and
not mumbling and not fading off on the end of your words.
This thing isn't,
this thing is a goldmine.
This book,
actually,
this should be issued to 13 year olds nationwide in my opinion.
Maybe we could start a campaign to make that happen.
Go back to the book carefulness in the little things count counts much.
Men develop an aversion to the individual who can not remember their names,
their titles,
or their stations,
but they will warm to the person who remembers and they will overlook most of
his other shortcomings.
Likewise,
they one by any words of appreciation or of interest in what they're doing.
So again,
how we get along with other people,
remember their name.
I know.
And that's hard.
You know,
bro,
that's hard.
There's tricks for that.
Yeah,
I know.
That's the,
you need tricks for it.
Even everyone needs,
but I'm just saying it's understood that that's hard and there's tricks out
there because people know that that can be hard and they also know that it's
impactful.
Yeah.
It's an impactful.
Yeah,
man.
But you forget the guys name.
Literally two seconds.
Bless you.
Unless you make it a point to command yourself to remember it.
Right.
That's tricky.
It's tricky.
I've,
I knew a guy that was,
uh,
a really good leader,
but he would go into a room of 25 people and he would go,
he would go over the top and when he got done,
he would say,
I know all your names now.
And he'd go name every single 100 does that.
It's legit.
I bet henders got some little trick to do it.
Yeah,
he remembers you know,
you,
oh,
your name is echo.
Cool.
I look at you and I th I see big e on your face right now.
I remember it.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
But man,
sometimes you can be like,
Hey,
I'm gonna make it a point to remember that one guy.
I'm going to make it a point to remember this guy's name.
He'll be like,
Hey,
my name is John.
You'd be like,
Hey,
Josh Brown,
you'll forget it quick sometimes.
It's weird,
man.
Not Good.
Got to remember those names.
You got to lock them in.
I think if you take a certain amount of pride in doing that,
I think that helps us.
Step number one,
take pride in your job.
I'm going to try that now.
This is,
this is an interesting little dig here.
It's actually kind of funny.
He's basically going back and saying that all this information about getting
along with other people,
he's saying he's kind of recapping the whole thing to close it out.
Back to the book.
It isn't lengthy advice which is needed on this subject.
Since a man commissioned is considered to have graduated from at least the
kindergarten of good manners,
what counts is simply caring about it and not,
not to be ingratiating to other people,
but for the sake of one's own dignity and self respect.
None of the oracles on winning friends and influencing people have said it in
those few words,
and if they had,
there would have been no books to sell.
So there's a little shot,
little shot on a winning friends and influencing people.
You,
when was Ellen right then?
Oh,
that,
that was written.
I don't know what the date dates,
but that's right.
A long time ago.
Dang.
Okay.
Long term.
Don't worry.
No,
that's,
that's turn of the century old school.
Old School.
Talking about now we're going to leader leaders in leadership and what type of
men are leaders,
those who come forward to fill the same places and to command them with equal or
greater or 40 and competence will not be plaster St.
So if you remember in the beginning,
you know he goes on this thing about how you view you,
you're not going to swear and you're going to be not going to talk bad about
women.
He's given some leeway now to that saying they're not going to be plaster Saints
Laden With All Human Virtue,
spotless and character and fit to be anointed with a superman legend by some
future Parson Weems.
They will be men with the human quality and a strong belief in the United States
and the goodness of a free society.
They will have some of the average man's faults and maybe a few of his vices,
but certainly they will possess the qualities of courage,
creative intelligence and physical fitness in more than average measure.
So again,
there's not as,
it's not quite as strict as he laid out in the beginning.
Yeah.
Cause it's like,
remember on Trey you to training day,
remember that Denzel and then I saw part of it,
the little concept is in there where he said you got to have a little dirt on
you so they can trust you.
Okay.
So basically if you have to sneaky clean.
Well yeah,
I mean like there's all kinds of heroes that are not as squeaky clean and all
kinds of leaders that aren't,
I would say there's more heroes that aren't squeaky clean.
Yeah.
They're real person.
Plenty of leaders that aren't squeaky clean and they're great leaders.
And that's what they're given that up in this book is saying,
look,
not going to be a plaster site.
You gotta be a person going to have faults or weaknesses going to have vices to
have dirt.
Yeah.
Just a little bit.
A little bit.
Yeah.
For the record,
the training day guys were all corrupt.
So that's a little bit of an extreme example.
They a little too much dirt.
All right,
so now we're talking about grant general grant,
civil war general and beset by human failings.
He could not look impressive.
Impressive.
Average,
though he was in many things.
There was nothing average about the strong way in which he took hold,
applying massive common sense to the complex problems of the field.
That is why he is worth close regard his virtues.
As a military leader,
we're of the simpler sort,
which plane men may understand and hope to emulate.
He was direct and manner.
He never intrigued.
His speech was homely,
he was approachable.
His mind never deviated from the object.
Though a stubborn man,
he was always willing to listen to his subordinates.
And I love this one right here.
He never adhered to a plan obstinately but nothing could induce him to forsake
the idea behind the plan.
So look,
I'm not going to say,
here's my idea and I'm going to hold that idea cause it's good,
but the plan that's going to get us there,
I'm not too worried about that.
I'm not going to hold onto that and let it drag me into the ground.
Back to the book.
In the military service services though,
there are niches for the pet damped character is at all times at least as vital
as intellect.
So today is like overly educated type scenario or you know you're pedantic,
right,
and the main rewards go to him.
Who can make other men feel toughened as well as elevated.
Here's some traits here.
Quiet resolution,
the hardy hood to take risks,
the will to take full responsibility for decisions,
the readiness to share its rewards with subordinates.
This is obviously extreme ownership and part of extreme ownership is when you'd
something that goes well.
You don't own that part.
You give that away
and equal readiness to take the blame when things go adversely,
boom.
The nerve to survive storm and disappointment and to face towards each new day
with this score sheet wiped clean,
neither dwelling on one successes nor accepting discouragement from one's
failures.
Like I said,
this book should be issued to 13 year old.
Really good book by the way.
I figured he'd dig this one.
I used a lot of highlighter on this one.
I've had this book for a long time.
I couldn't,
it's funny when I read it this time,
I hadn't read it in so long that it was almost like I was reading it again.
I pretty much had forgotten most of it and a lot of it,
you know,
I subconsciously was part Venn probably part of my game for a long time.
Yeah.
I can't tell though.
I can't tell what I just,
what I buried and what,
what was the seed that grew?
Yeah.
Probably there's some ideas in here that were seeds,
if my thought,
yeah,
I would imagine so that that's not the kind of book where it's like,
Oh yeah,
let me memorize all this.
You know,
it's more like,
oh shoot,
I gotta I gotta Kinda in Jeff and his idea and here's the straight up truth.
When somebody gave me this book,
I probably read 10 pages of it and said,
oh,
this is pretty cool.
Put it in my locker and then went out and worked out and forgot about it for
next 15 years.
So it's not,
I didn't,
you know,
this,
this current Jocko we'll call it where I kind of overlay and in bring in,
it's like Jujitsu when you don't,
when you're good at Jujitsu,
you if you're no,
if you're a brown belt,
purple belt,
the black belt in Jujitsu,
somebody can show you a move and you can assimilate it really quickly and you
go,
oh yeah,
all I need you to do is this.
Well,
I was a white belt before in this stuff and so when I'd read it,
it kind of made sense,
but it was,
it was,
didn't make as much sense as that.
When I read this stuff now it's like I totally understand it at a deeper level
and so it's way more impactful for me.
People are always asking me about this one as well.
Back to the book to speak of the importance of a sense of humor would be
unavailing if it were not that what cramps so many men isn't that they are by
nature humorless,
but that they are hesitant to exercise what humor they possess
within the military profession.
It is unwise to let the muscles go soft and to spare the mind the strain of
original thinking.
Okay,
great.
Humor has always been in the military tradition.
People ask for some reason,
people ask me about humor a lot.
Hmm.
Hey,
isn't it good for an officer to it or isn't it good for a leader to tell Joe?
And like,
yes it is.
And that's why I always,
whenever there's something funny in the war books that we read,
I always try and capture that.
So then people realize that these guys are out there and they keep that sense of
humor going all the time.
Yeah.
And I guess it doesn't really necessarily mean telling jokes all the time,
just like 11 yeah.
I feel that's funny.
I'm going to,
you know.
Yeah.
This just having a good time making,
making light of these miserable situations for sure.
Hmm.
Said Admiral,
this is going into the next chapter,
which is called main springs of leadership
said Ab rule,
forest p Sherman,
chief of naval operations.
I concur that we can take average good men and by proper training developing
them the essential initiative,
concert,
confidence and magnetism which are necessary in leadership.
I believe that these qualities are present in the average man to a degree that
he can be made a good leader if his native qualities are properly developed.
Whether or not he becomes a great leader depends upon whether or not he
possesses that extra initiative,
magnetism,
moral courage and force,
which makes the difference between the average man and the above.
Average man said,
General CB,
Kate's commandant of the Marine Corps leadership is intangible,
hard to measure and difficult to describe.
It's qualities would seem to stem from many factors,
but certainly they must include a measure of inherent ability to control and
direct self confidence based on expert knowledge,
initiative,
loyalty,
pride and sense of responsibility.
Inherent ability obviously cannot be instilled but that which is latent or
dormant can be developed.
Other ingredients can be acquired.
They are not easily taught or easily learned,
but leaders can be and can be and are made.
The average good man and our service is and must be considered a potential
leader.
So there you go to that question.
It's the same answer that I give them basically all the time when people ask me
if leaders leaders are born or may or made,
there's the answer from these two guys.
They agree with me or should I say I agree with them since they are senior to
me.
But,
but look,
you got certain traits you can take.
I would say,
look,
you can take someone that's an okay leader and make them a better leader.
You can take a good leader and make them an outstanding leader and outstanding
leader.
You can make an a rapid leader because you're gonna improve these things.
You can learn about these things.
The one person that you can't make any better as the person that's not humble,
they're not going to get any better cause they can't be coached because Danny
and his own light cause he's standing in his own light.
Maybe we'll bring that back him and bringing that
back to the book.
And before I go back to the book,
this is another thing I get asked about a lot,
is people ask me because they know that I work a lot.
Yeah.
They know that I get after it.
Right.
And they asked and they asked me about,
uh,
you know,
how do you,
how do you do with your family?
You've got a family.
Cause I've got four children and a wife.
Sure.
And a goldfish.
Okay.
Icicle.
That's the name.
That's the name I know.
So I got to give to the family,
right.
So people say,
hey,
how do you,
how do you balance?
So here we go back to the book.
Personal advancement within any worthwhile system requires some sacrifice of
leisure and more careful attention to the better organization of one's working
routine.
But that does not entail heroic self sacrifice or for fitting of any of life's
truly enduring rewards.
It means the completion of work ahead of Gulf.
Yeah.
So,
so,
so often you see people that you don't,
you're just,
I'm not going to work myself to death.
Oh,
okay.
Are you going to play golf to death?
Because that's apparently what you're trying to do here.
Right.
But yeah,
you got to find balance.
You got to find balance.
Especially,
you know when he's talking about life's truly and dory rewards,
that's talking about your family and the things that you achieve outside of the
work world.
Hmm.
Abby dim net and Abby Abby dim net was a priest,
I'm pretty sure priest and wrote a book called the art of thinking and he's
quoted here in this book,
he said concentration is supposed to be exceptional only because people do not
try and in this as so many things starve within an inch of Plenti.
Ooh,
I like that quote.
Starve within an inch of plenty.
You're almost there.
Almost there.
Almost got plenty.
But your starve to death right there within an inch.
Why?
Cause you,
you failed a concentrate,
you failed to focus and that's what happens.
Oh and well this is,
this is just awesome.
Here we go.
There is of course that communist of excuses for rejecting the difficult and
taking life easy.
I haven't time,
but for the man who keeps his mind on the object,
there is always time figure it out about us in the service as daily we see busy
men who somehow managed to find time for whatever is worth doing while at the
adjoining desks are others with abundant leisure who can't find time for
anything when something important requires doing is usually the busy man who
gets the call.
Okay.
Haven't got time for that,
Huh?
There's always time.
Always time.
And how can you ever have time
if you don't take time?
That sounds cool,
but I don't know what it means.
Expand.
Oh,
who has time?
Ah,
but ah,
how can you ever have time if you don't take,
oh,
so you're going to take it out.
Okay.
Patrick given,
is that where it's like park or something like that?
Do some,
there was a part two to that movie.
I think there's like a part three.
Two.
Wow.
Anyway,
that was,
that was a good one.
It's true though.
You know,
like guys will be like,
Hey,
I wanna um,
I want to get in really good shape or something.
Like this,
I want to get like real strong or whatever.
I was like,
okay,
I'm gonna work out like this.
May I don't have like time to wolf then you don't have time,
then you then you can't get in shape.
It's like saying I don't have the inclination,
it's more or less the same
thing.
I don't have the time.
Yeah.
I was with one of my buddies and we were counseling someone and my buddy said
you don't care about this.
And the guy says no,
no I do care.
And he said,
well why can't you show up on time if you cared you would show up on time.
Right.
And case closed.
You were fired.
That was that.
I was like,
well you know what,
let's just stop talking cause we're done.
We're done.
Cause that's 100% accurate.
So as you probably know,
I come from a long line of late.
Yes we've,
we've discussed that before.
So I kind of analyzed it where there was a time where I felt like,
Dang,
I just,
I don't know.
I just can't be on to,
it's like,
it's like almost like this,
like a mentor,
physical block almost.
That's what it felt like,
but then
really amylase,
this is when you really realize that you are just lazy,
not lazy.
It wasn't important.
Just like,
are you saying this is what?
So let's say work for example.
I was late literally more times than I was on time at work.
I won't ever forget her name.
So many times I did a good enough job.
I would have fired you and then rehired you so I could fire you.
Just Starkey,
take pleasure in it.
Probably would have been a good idea nonetheless.
So when I analyze it,
I was like,
wait,
why am I late?
Why don't I get prepared the night before?
Whatever it takes to be on time every single time and just like,
it's not important.
Like why would I spend my off work time preparing to go be at work?
I should be resting or d,
that's my off time.
Watching a little bit more television or yeah,
whatever.
Not Working.
I can squeeze in another episode of this program.
Exactly right.
Not Working.
Why should I spend off work time doing work,
stuff like that.
I'm not getting paid.
We're kind of thing,
you know,
it's not important that it goes back to this whole,
this whole book starting off with the attitude of trying to do good job all the
time.
And actually somebody brought that up.
If somebody sent me a direct message,
and this was a great point that I didn't think about,
we got asked another question on the podcast about,
hey,
if you're getting told to go to a meeting that you're not going to get paid for
a,
remember that conversation?
This guy wrote me and said,
hey,
you know,
legally that that's illegal if you're on an hourly rage.
So that's a great point that I didn't think of.
I didn't think of it from a HR perspective,
but that's a good point.
Now you've got people that you're breaking the law.
So I kind of assume that these guys were not being specifically compensated,
but that they,
they were maybe salaried employees that they were,
but I could be wrong.
And if those people are hourly now you,
now you,
now you've got to go to the boss and say,
Hey boss,
I want to get this meeting going,
but what you're doing to us and what you're doing to these guys is illegal.
Or maybe the manager,
a lot of times managers are salaried and the workers are hourly,
so he would need to go,
look,
I'll come to the meeting because I'm on salary.
It's all good with me.
I'm here to win.
But the guys,
I can't bring them in here unless you want to be looking at a,
at a labor law suit,
you and the game for that boss because I'm not,
that's going to cost our company money.
It's gonna make us look bad.
Let's,
let's do this another way.
Yeah,
boom.
But that is a different element to the whole,
like the point as far as what you're talking,
what are you talking about?
Like if something's like not important versus it is important,
like it doesn't necessarily go for just worked it.
So he goes for anything.
Like if you're late to anything,
like if you,
if you like this podcast I'm rolling in late every single time it's,
it's obviously because being on time isn't that important and that bleeds into
this podcast in one way or another.
What we're about to do isn't important enough and that's why you're on time
because it is important to you.
There you go.
Oh,
I'm glad.
Cause it's important to me too.
And I will spin off my quote unquote free time doing stuff to prepare for,
you know the ontime stuff.
Well that's good.
You see what I'm saying?
Otherwise you'd be getting fired.
I'm just using this as a high.
Give me another echo.
Charles,
you got a twin brother,
right?
Don't even know the difference.
Good point.
Although he probably genetically has the same problem.
I told you,
we come from a long line and he knows the importance of,
you know,
the,
and it's,
and it's a sign of disrespect to,
by the way,
it's like saying,
not only do I not think what we're,
what we've planned to do or agreed to do and all this type stuff.
Not only do I not think that's important,
I don't respect how much you think it's important.
That's why I need to respect my time.
Nope.
None at all.
The on time.
Well and make time.
Take your time.
If you want to have the time you get a picture.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's what's so I like about this guys actually making fun of people that say I
haven't got time
because for the man who keeps his mind on the object,
there is always time.
Okay.
Next section says much as conveyed an F in few words.
In army field forces brief on practical concepts of leadership.
It is stressed.
They're in that the preeminent quality,
which all great commanders have owned in common is a positiveness of manner and
a viewpoint.
The power to concentrate on means to a given end to the exclusion of exaggerated
fears of the obstacles which ally a fort the course.
Every word of that should be underscored and above all what it says about the
need for affirmative thinking and concentrating on how things can be done.
This is the PR you always hear about this.
You always hear about this person,
the person that says when you go to them and say,
Hey,
can we do this?
They're,
they're always looking for a way to say no.
Our reason why something can't happen instead of,
no,
we can do that.
We can make that happen.
We can,
we can figure out a way.
That's what we're looking for.
Next section,
those.
Okay.
Oh,
in this section is actually the same topic of what this podcast is the topic of
and that is human nature
legit.
Those who had the chance to study American men under the terrible rigor of
Japanese imprisonment during World War Two gave an analysis that in certain of
the prisoners,
character and sanity with it held fast against every circumstance in others,
some of whom had been well educated and came from gentle homes.
The brute instinct was as upper most as in an east African Cannibal.
And when they say brute instinct,
that's the person that just loses and goes to the animal instincts.
Hmm.
From such crucibles as these even more than from the remittance stresses of
combat in war comes the clearest light on the inner nature of man in so far as
it needs to be understood by the officer who may some day lead a force into
battle
human nature.
One of the things that he says about cumin nature and here is goodwill and
weakness may be combined in one man,
bad will and strength in another.
Hi moral leading can lift the first man to excel himself.
It will not reform the other,
but there is no other sensible rule then that all men will be approached with
trust and treated as trough trustworthy until proved otherwise beyond reasonable
doubt.
So He's thrown out.
The trust is a little bit opposite.
I've talked about it or it's like,
actually I should take that back.
I remember one time on the podcast,
I said,
look,
I don't have a high expectation of people when I meet him and I hold that true
to this day,
but I don't straight up not trust them as a human.
Yeah,
there's a difference there.
Yes.
I think there's a difference.
I think I feel that way.
There is a d yeah.
And,
and it's not an obvious difference,
but it's like the difference between,
I don't have an a high expectation of somebody's aunt versus I have a low
expectation of person.
Got It.
So yeah.
But it does sound the same though.
It sounds the same expectation than what can expectation do you have obviously a
low one.
Right,
exactly.
Right.
Maybe just to maybe just a neutral one.
Right?
Like I'm not gonna put any expectations.
I'm not expecting you to do a bunch of hero,
you know,
I don't have any expectations.
Neutral.
Yeah.
I think I come up,
come in with a neutral attitude on that one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Back to the book.
Men Do not achieve a great solidarity or preserve it simply by being together.
They're mutual.
Bonds are forged only by doing that which they have been convinced is
constructive.
The absence of a common purpose is that chief source of unhappiness in any
collection of individuals lacking it and the common standard of justice,
which is one of its chief agents,
men become more and more separate units each fighting for his own rights.
This is why you got to have that common purpose.
This is why that commander's intent is so important.
This is why it's important that everyone understood.
It has to understand why they're doing what they're doing.
They have to understand the strategic goal that you're trying to meet as a
company,
as a business,
as a team,
as a platoon
and as a person and less like a lot of people.
They'd go into straight up depression because I mean if I don't see the big
goal,
if they don't feel purpose in their life map,
yeah,
that is true.
Back to the book,
whatever his rank,
it is impossible for any man to lead if he is himself running behind this
bespeaks the need of constant study,
the constant use of one's personal powers and the exercise of the imagination as
men advance that which was good soon ceases to be good simply because something
better is possible.
You got to evolve.
You've got to continue to evolve,
get to continue to improve yourself.
History confirms and a study of the workings of the human mind supports one
proposition which many of the great captains of war have accepted as a truism.
There are no bad troops.
There are only bad leaders.
Yeah,
interesting.
It's here.
Napoleon set.
Napoleon said there's no bad colonels,
only bad regiments.
Hackworth said the same thing.
No bad t I think he said,
no bad troops,
only bad officers in the book that Lafe and I wrote,
no bad teams,
only bad leaders.
So
very common
and very true stands the test of time.
You know,
there's a reason why Napoleon thought that there's a reason why SLA Marshall
said that there's a reason why Hackworth said that there's a reason why Lafe and
I put that in the book because that is true.
And the minute you,
if you're in a leadership position,
the minute that you accept that fact is the minute you step forward to becoming
a better leader.
Because as soon as you're blaming it on other people,
you're,
you're just not going to make about,
oh,
my team sucks.
You suck.
Right?
So it's,
I don't know if you'd call this irony or what,
but,
okay.
No bad teams.
Only bad leaders.
So if you're like,
wait,
that's not true.
Well guess what?
Your bed.
Yeah,
it's,
it's like a catch 22 yeah.
Or what's good for the goose is good for the Gander.
Actually.
I don't think that's it,
but all right,
this is awesome.
Here we go back to the book and this actually,
this section here has gone to group nature,
so we've gone from human nature to group nature.
Back to the book,
among the Communist of experiences in war is to witness troops doing nothing or
worse doing the wrong thing without one commanding voice,
being raised to give them direction.
In such circumstance,
any man who has the nerve and presence to step forward and give them an
intelligent order in a manner indicating that he expects to be obeyed,
will be accepted as a leader and will be given their support.
Did you hear that?
I did.
That's all it is.
Who's going to step up?
Who's going to have the nerve and the presence to step up and give it an
intelligent order that you believe in and that you believe will be followed on?
I get you would expect we'll bid,
you'll be obeyed.
So again,
I hear all these people say,
well,
you know,
I'm not in the senior position,
therefore I can't do anything wrong.
Actually you can step up and lead
back to the book.
For this reason.
Under the conditions of modern battle,
the coherence of any military body comes not only of men being articulate all
down the line,
but of building up the dynamic power in each individual.
It is a thoroughly sound exercise in any unit to give every man a chance to take
charge and give orders in drill or other limited exercises.
Once he has learned what the orders mean,
by the same token,
it is good practice for the junior leader to displace a file that means just one
of the guys to displace a file in a training exercise and become commanded for a
time to sharpen his own perspective.
So
it's good for the junior guys to step up into leadership positions in lead.
It's good for the leaders to go and be one of the boys and the platoon.
And I got really lucky because I was at prior,
what's called a prior enlisted guy,
a Mustang officers.
So I spent my first eight years in the seal teams as a,
as a guy in the,
I was one of the files.
So I knew what it was like when a leader didn't tell you know what was going on.
I knew what it was like when you had a good leader.
Yeah.
So when I stepped up into those leadership positions,
I could,
I knew at least what not to do and I knew what I would try and do to be a good
leader.
Yeah.
It's like the curse of knowledge,
right?
Like you don't Chris sinologist when like you can't see it from some
inexperienced persons point of view.
Oh Yup.
Yup.
And so you don't really have that,
you know,
cause you've been the inexperience.
He can just draw on those memories,
you know,
to have that perspective though full kind of know what it is like to good won't
want to worst things.
You're at the end of a 16 man seal platoon patrolling through the night and you
just have no idea where you are.
You have no idea how far the target is.
A way you have no idea when you're going to stop.
You have no idea what you've,
no idea of anything.
You're just walking like a like a miserable or boots,
boots,
boots.
That's what you're getting the zone off.
It's just the worst.
So when I was a platoon commander,
when I was a squad leader,
everybody I tried with everything.
I had to make sure everyone knew what's going on.
Yeah,
all the time because I never wanted my guys to be thinking what is happening?
What are we doing?
Yeah,
that's good.
Progress comes of making the most of our strengths rather than looking for ways
to repair weaknesses.
This is true in things both large and small.
The platoon leader who permits himself to beat bedeviled by the file who won't
or can't keep step,
cannot do justice to the ambitions of the 10 strongest men beneath him.
I'll pawn to whom the life of the formation would depend common emergency to
nourish and encourage the top rather than to concentrate effort and exhaust
nerves and trying to correct a few,
least likely prospects is the healthy way of growth within military
organization.
Take care of your top people,
put your foe folks and energy in them.
And I was,
you know,
going to give some time to the guys that are struggling.
Try and help them out.
But let's not focus on them.
They're not gonna make or break you.
So those leaders that you want to,
you want to develop,
you want to,
you've got a good seed that's starting to grow water,
that seed.
Don't worry about that thing over there in the corner that's not doing anything.
It is a good,
this is classic.
It is a sign of a good level of discipline in command when orders are given and
faithfully carried out.
But it is a sign of a vastly superior condition when the men are prepared to
demand those orders,
which they know the situation requires.
If it is to be helped.
No competence.
Subordinate sits around waiting for someone else to give impulse to movement.
If he senses,
if it senses tell him that things are going to pot,
either suggests a course of action to it's superior or asks authority to execute
it on his own or in the more desperate circumstances of the battlefield gives
orders on his own initiative.
Decentralized Command.
Everybody's a leader.
Everybody steps up and makes things happen.
Okay.
Back to the book General Dwight d Eisenhower was thinking on these things when
he said during World War II,
there is among the mass of individuals who carry rifles in war,
a great amount of ingenuity and efficiency.
If men can talk naturally to their officers,
the product of their resourcefulness becomes available to all.
So as long as you can,
as long as your guys feel comfortable talking to you,
you're going to have access to all their ideas and all their ingenuity back to
the book.
But the art of open communication requires both receiving an ending.
And the besetting problem is to get officers to talk naturally to men.
Develop the relationships with the troops is what you gotta do.
Okay?
Another section here at all.
Training,
all training at all levels has a dual object to develop us all as leaders of men
and as followers of leaders.
Dichotomy.
Got To be a leader,
got to be a follower.
It's like your Twitter thing and know your Twitter,
bio leader,
follower over eager listener
reader.
That is,
that is,
there's a dichotomy there.
Okay,
back to the book.
The paralysis which comes of fear can be lifted only through the resumption of
action,
which will again give individuals the feeling of organization.
So this is interesting.
We remember that
Joe Owen when he was in Korea in the coldest war in,
in colder than hell,
he's freezing and he,
there's shooting starts and he's got his own procedure of how he's going to
overcome the fear he's going to do.
He's going to take action.
And it's something that I've said on here a bunch of times here.
You're afraid to something take action and step into it.
So what this,
what this is saying is the same thing but not on an individual level,
but on a group level.
Because we're talking about group nature here and it's the same thing as you do
with an individual you do with the group.
So listen to this again,
the paralysis which comes a fear can be lifted only through the resumption of
action,
which will again give the individuals feeling of organization.
This does not mean ordering a bayonet charge or firing a volley at such and such
a clock.
It may mean only padding one man on the back talking it up to a couple of
others,
sending someone out to find a flank or turning ones or turning oneself to dig in
while passing the word to others to do.
Likewise,
this is action in the realest sense of the term.
Out of rear reinvigorating men toward the taking of many small actions develops
the possibility of large and decisive action.
That unit must first find itself before doing an effective job of finding the
enemy.
Out of those acts which are incidental to the establishing of an order,
the leader reaffirms his own power of decision.
So those are,
that's beautiful advice.
Beautiful advice.
Just like you do with yourself,
you're afraid of something.
Take action step into it.
You got your group and everyone started to get scared and overwhelmed.
Let's take some action.
Hey guys,
dig in.
online,
whatever that order is going to be.
That's that.
It may not solve the problem,
but it regains your,
your stability as a team and now you can move forward.
Yeah.
This next section is subtitled environment.
Back to the book.
It is only to the man who is burdened with unnecessary,
an exaggerated fear,
fears and who mistakes for fancied security.
The privilege of sitting quietly in one place that the uprooting which comes
with war is demoralizing.
The natural officer sees it as an hour of opportunity and though he may not like
anything else about war,
he at least relishes the strong feeling of personal contention which always
develop,
develops when there are many openings inviting many men as world as one World
War II commander expressed it during war.
The ball is always kicking around,
loose in the middle of the field,
and any man who has the will may pick it up and run with it.
That's true by life.
So many opportunities out there who's going to pick it up and run with it
becomes the question.
Yeah.
Now we get into touching back a little bit on to some discipline back to the
book when men are given absolute freedom with no compulsion upon them,
but to eat and sleep as with a group of south sea savages,
there can be no strong uniting bond between them.
Yeah.
Absolute freedom doesn't get you what you want.
There's gotta be a counter to that and that counter is discipline.
I suppose that's another politically incorrect thing that we've run into the
book a couple of times.
The South Sea savages whose that technically probably natives from the South
Sea.
Yes,
yes.
In fact,
that is who it is.
Okay.
All right.
There you go.
No offense intended
back to the book in officer Schipp.
There is simply no substitute for personal recognizance nor any other technique
that in the long run we'll have half its value.
So when he's talking about personal recognizance,
here's not talking about going to reconnaissance reconnaissance of an enemy
position.
He's talking about going down and Rocana syncing,
doing reconnaissance within your own element,
talking to your peoples.
What he's talking about here,
he's talking about that
habit of,
of personal recognizance once formed the habit of getting down to the roots of
organ,
of organization,
of seeing with one's own eyes.
What is taking place of measuring it against one's own scale of values,
of ordering such changes as are needed and a following through to make certain
that the changes are made becomes the main spring of all efficient command
action in battle.
There is no other way to be sure in training.
There is no better way to move towards self assurance,
so get down there,
get in the weeds sometimes,
see what's going on on the front lines.
Talk to your people.
This section talks about the mission.
When an order is given,
what are the responsibilities of the man who receives it in sequence these to be
certain that he understands what is required to examine an organize his
resources as promptly as possible to and fully informed his subordinates upon
these points to execute the order without waste of time or means to call for
support.
If events prove that his means are inadequate to fill up the spaces in the
orders.
If there are developments which had not been anticipated
when the detail is complete to prepare to go on to something else.
Straightforward.
Lieutenant General Sir Frederick Morgan who planned the invasion of Normandy,
put the matter this way.
When setting out on any enterprise it is well,
it is as well to ask oneself three questions.
To whom is one responsible for what precisely is one responsible?
What are the means that disposable at disposal for discharging this
responsibility?
Nothing so warms the heart of a superior as that on giving an order.
He sees his subordinate salute and say yes sir.
Then about face and proceeded to carry it out to the hilt without faltering or
looking back.
This is the kind of a man that a commander will choose to have with him every
time and that he will recommend for first advancement.
Okay.
On the other hand,
clarification of the object is not only a right but a duty and it cuts both
ways.
So if you don't understand you,
it's you.
You,
you have the duty to ask for clarification.
Orders are not always clear and no superior is on form from ground.
When he is impatient of questions which are to the point or resentful of the man
who asks him.
I say this all the time.
If you're a subordinate says,
hey,
why are we doing this?
And you get angry,
you're wrong.
You should be happy that your subordinates asking why,
but it is the but it is natural that he will be doubtful of the man whose word
show either that he hasn't heard or is concerned.
Mainly with irrelevancies.
A cultivation of the habit of careful,
concentrated listening and have collected,
fought in reading into any problem is principal portal to successful officer
ship
from the pen,
from the pen of General Eisenhower comes these words,
the commander success will be measured more by his ability to lead then by his
adherence to fixed notions.
Thus in the conduct of operations,
not less than an execution of orders,
it is necessary that the mind remain plastic and impressionable.
Again,
the idea of the military man as this person that can't change and is close
minded,
it's wrong.
Now there are military leaders like that
and it's unfortunate they're not good.
You gotta have the flexible mind.
You gotta have the plastic mind.
Okay?
Obedience is not the product of fear,
but of understanding and understanding is based on knowledge that you've got to
make sure that your troops don't understand what's going on so they know what's
going on so they can obey properly.
Not out of fear.
To grasp the spirit of orders is not less important.
Then to accept them cheerfully and keep faith with the contract,
but the letter of an instruction does not relieve him who receives it from the
obligation to exercise.
Common Sense.
You get told to do something,
you still got to do.
You still gotta hold common sense.
In the Carolina maneuvers of 1941 a soldier stood at a road intersection for
three days and nights directing civilian traffic simply because the man who put
him there had forgotten all about it.
Though he was praised at the time,
he was a hardly a shining example of the hold up to the troops.
Moving into the next chapter,
which the name of the chapter is discipline.
This is,
you're going to recognize this one.
Once a man condones remiss,
his own belief and discipline begins to wither.
The officer who tolerate slackness in the dress of his men soon ceases to attend
his own appearance and if he is not called to account,
has sloppy habits will shortly begin to inflict his superior.
There's only one correct way to wear the uniform when any deviations and dress
or condoned within the services.
The way is open to the destruction of all uniformity and unity.
It's not what you preach,
it's what you tolerate.
You can don't remixes
you're opening.
Now this might be a little bit extreme when he says that when you're out of
uniform or you allow these units of the way is open to the destruction of all
uniformity and unity.
I'm not sure I 100% agree with that and I was always very pro uniform and making
sure that guys were squared away in their uniforms.
I was probably the one of the most stringent in the seal teams in the seal teams
is not,
uniforms are not,
we're not real good at wear uniforms and looking good and uniforms and being
squared away in uniform.
So it's kind of hard for me to agree that that opens up the way for the
destruction of all uniformity.
But the lesson here is,
is it more about the uniforms?
It's more about just,
it's not what you preach it to what your dollar,
right?
Yeah.
That slippery slope situation.
Yes.
It is.
Well opening the ways that necessarily insuring something true.
True,
true.
I'll give it to you.
Technically.
You get me on the technicality sometimes.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Okay.
With that,
I'm plastic in my mind and I can,
I can accept that plastic.
You know how some people say plastic like,
oh that guys look plastic meaning like he's fake or something like that.
This is for like,
like plasticity.
Yes,
absolutely.
Written in 1950 before plastic was everything that we used.
Yeah.
I used to have this theory that anything that was made of metal was better.
It just make everything of metal.
I wanted to make everything that was made metal.
Right.
Don't they see stuff?
That,
same thing about like food and Bacon.
I like anything with Bacon as best similar.
It's the same kind of thing would be correct.
Yeah.
Good.
Back to the book.
No leader ever fails his men,
nor will they fail him.
Who leads them in respect for the disciplined life.
Okay.
Between these two things,
discipline in itself and a personal faith in the military.
Value of discipline lies all the difference between military maturity and
mediocrity.
A salute from an unwilling man is as meaningless as the moving of a leaf on a
tree.
It is a sign only that the subject has been caught by a gust of wind,
but a salute from the man who takes pride in the gesture because he feels
privileged to wear the uniform of the United States.
Having found the service good is the epitome of military virtue.
Okay.
Until men are severely tried,
there is no conclusive test of their discipline nor proof that their training at
arms is satisfying a legitimate military end.
Military forces relatively undisciplined until physically toughened and mentally
conditioned to unusual exertion.
Consider the road march.
No body of men could possibly enjoy the dust,
the heat,
the blistered foot and the aching back,
but hard road marching is necessary if a sound foundation is to be built under
the discipline of fighting forces,
particularly those whose labors are in the field and the gain comes quickly.
The rise in spirits within any organization which is always to be observed after
they rebound from a hard marsh does not come essentially from the feeling of
relief that the strain is past.
But rather from the satisfaction that a goal has been crossed,
it must be accepted.
That discipline does not break down under the strain of placing a testing demand
upon the individual.
It is sloppy off and not activity that destroys discipline.
Think about that one.
So the,
it's not the strain,
it's not the pressure that you put that breaks down the discipline.
It's the laziness.
It's the slop that breaks discipline.
Troops can endure hard going when it serves an understandable end.
This is what they will boast about.
Mainly when the fatigue has ended,
a large part of training is necessarily directed toward conditioning them for
unusual hardship and privation.
They can take it in stride,
but no power on earth can reconcile them to what common sense tells them is
unnecessary hardship,
which might have been avoided by greater intelligence in their superiors.
So if you're telling people to do something and they realize that there's an
easier way to do it there,
they're going to be angry.
When they are overloaded,
they know it when they were required to form a parade two hours ahead of time
because their commander got overanxious or didn't know how to write an order
again,
they know it and they are perfectly right if they go sour because this kind of
thing happens a little too often within the command,
within our system,
that discipline is nearest perfect,
which assures to the individual the greatest freedom of thought and action
while at all times promoting his feeling of responsibility toward the group.
The Greg,
do you hear about the greatest form of discipline is the one that gives the
greatest freedom of thought and action.
That's what we want.
Okay.
Want the discipline equal freedom.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
His take on like when you go through some hard stuff,
the satisfaction isn't that it's over.
It's the fact that you did.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
It's like,
okay,
you know,
I told you my whole sleep thing.
Well,
he used to be worth,
if I didn't get my eight and a half hours,
I was done for the day.
But so now let's say get two hours sleep and I'm like,
Hey,
I'm going to,
I'm going to still do this,
a workout,
whatever.
This conditioning something hard.
Sure.
It's going to be hard.
I'm not looking forward to it,
but yeah,
the satisfaction is afterwards all even go how it said you're going to have
something to brag about or something like that.
That's true.
You go and tell your friends,
hey,
I did this.
I only had two hours sleep natured anyways.
Yeah.
You do kind of have that feeling like you want to brag about it.
No doubt.
Like I did some hard stuff.
You know,
it's,
we shouldn't be surprised.
We're kind of getting excited when these things completely makes sense.
Yeah.
These are the,
these are,
these are generals that knew and understand human nature.
Yeah.
And these are things that we look at and we learn.
We've experienced.
Yeah.
So it shouldn't come as a surprise.
I know.
It's crazy when you're,
it's like tunnel vision.
You know where it will happen and you'd almost like,
you don't even realize it will happen.
Like everyone does that.
Everyone does something that's hard for sure.
Gets through hard work day,
did something under the circumstances that they hate.
They might even be complaining about it like all this was going on.
So such a stressful day.
But when you get it actually done,
you brag about it at the very least that you feel like you want to brag about it
and keep that,
pursue that,
you know,
keep that up.
Now there's some counter to that.
Here we go back to the book.
If the man is cramped by monotonous routine or made to feel that he cannot move
unless an order as barked,
he can not develop these qualities and he will never come forward as a junior
leader.
So if you put too much discipline on somebody,
they're going to your grid,
crimp.
There's their leadership capabilities.
Say that all the time
in the words of do peak,
who saw so deeply into the hearts of fighting men.
If one does not wish bonds broken,
one should make them elastic and thereby strengthen them.
That's a guy he wrote.
He wrote a thing called the battle studies will actually,
he didn't finish right here cause he got killed in action fighting,
uh,
fighting.
Yeah.
Napolli with he was,
he was a French fighting again,
the in the,
I want to say fighting oppressions,
but he egg another,
a great quote from him
that I wrote down.
Nothing can be,
nothing.
Can wisely be prescribed an any army without exact knowledge of the fundamental
instrument of man and his State of mind,
his morale at the instant of combat.
So the,
you know,
the peak is a guy that really started looking at the,
the mentality of guys,
okay,
we're going to have to get it.
We're going to have to dive into him at some point.
Now speaking of morale,
next section is about morale.
Uh,
World War II,
Blah.
Blue Jackets said it this way,
blue jackets term for navy guys said it this way.
Morale was when your hands and feet keep working.
When your head says it can't be done.
The handiest beginning is to consider morale in conjunction with discipline.
Since in military service they are opposite sides of the same coin.
When one is present,
the other will also be there.
Morale and discipline,
morale and discipline.
They go together.
This is a familiar story.
It was repeated by the United States forces in World War II during the Normandy
headrow fighting and the invasions of the central Pacific atolls.
Troops had to learn the hard way,
how to hit,
how to survive in moving through jungle or across mountains and the desert.
When that happened,
the only disciplinary residue which mattered was obedience to orders.
The movements they had learned by rote were of less value than the spiritual
bond between one man and another.
The most valuable lesson was that of mutual support.
So this is awesome.
The moves,
the battle moves that they,
that they've learned,
that they trained that were hard and put them through this hard work.
You know,
getting ready to deploy overseas.
When they got overseas,
they were fighting in a hedgerow.
They never did that before.
They're fighting in the mountain.
So they had to take these,
these drills that they had learned to kind of throw them out the window.
So all they have left and the most valuable thing of all that training wasn't
the movements themselves.
It was this spiritual bond between these men that was more important than the
tactical maneuvers was the fact that they did hard training together and they
work together and they knew each other and they had that spiritual bond.
Yeah.
Back to the book in its essential discipline is not measured according to how a
man keeps step in a drill yard or whether he salutes at just the right angle.
The test is how well he willing,
willingly response to his superiors and all vital matters.
And finally,
whether he stands or runs when his life is at stake.
History makes this clear.
There are countless examples of successful military forces which had almost no
discipline when measured by the usual yardsticks,
yet had a high battle morale productive of the kind of discipline which beats
the enemy in battle.
So that's another little dichotomy.
You know what he's talking about,
like you might not be the most disciplined on the parade field,
but if you've got that bond,
you've got that discipline bond,
you can still come up with the victory.
This is important.
Back to the book,
man is able to recognize a right and reasonable
discipline as such,
even though it causes him personal inconvenience because he's he,
he has acquired a sense of military values,
but
if it is either unduly harsh or unnecessarily lax,
he likewise knows it and wears it as a hair shirt to the undoing of his morale.
Though the man like the group can be hurt by being pushed beyond sensible
limits,
his spirit will suffer even more sorely.
If no real test is put upon his abilities and moral powers,
the greater has intelligence,
the stronger will be his resentment.
That is the law of nature.
The enlightened mind has always the greatest measure of self discipline,
but it also has a higher sense of what constitutes justice fairplay and a
reasonable requirement in the performance of duty.
If denied these things,
he will come to hold his chief,
his job and himself in contempt.
Yeah.
So if you get the,
if you're a military leader,
if you're a civilian leader and you get the idea,
okay,
Jack was talking about discipline.
Discipline's key.
So you're going to come in and just throw discipline on your people and burden
them with this heavy realm of discipline.
It's not going to work out because everyone knows that it's unjust,
unfair,
unnecessary.
We don't want that unnecessary discipline,
but we embrace,
we might not outwardly,
but we deep inside,
we embrace the hardcore discipline,
if it makes sense and has meeting.
Hmm.
Admiral Ben Morrill has stated a formula and understanding terms by his
explanation of what made the CBS notable for competence and devotion to duty
during World War II.
What he said is this.
We used artisans to do the work for which they had been trained in civilian
life.
They were well led by officers who spoke their language.
We made them feel that they were playing an important part,
integrated venture,
and thus they achieved a high standard of morale.
The elements underscored by Admiral Marril deserve special note satisfaction in
a work program.
Mutual confidence between leaders and ranks.
Conviction that all together we're striving for something more important than
themselves.
Talking about the CBS,
the construction battalions in the navy that do engineering work.
Yeah,
overseas and I actually had CBS with us in Ramadi that were awesome,
awesome guys that did everything for us.
They kept everything going,
kept everything running,
kept everything working,
built everything that we used.
Awesome guys.
And every CB I've ever worked with has bit of just a just a beast.
They have that attitude like
they know they're gonna make their,
their,
their motto is,
can do and believe me when you tell him to do something,
there are 100% of that motto right there.
They're going to make it happen.
Here we go back to the book talking about morale under training conditions or
were in combat,
the mental ills and the resulting morale,
moral and physical deterioration,
which sometimes be set military forces cannot be cured simply by the
intensification of disciplinary methods.
Can't just turn it up.
[inaudible].
It is true that the signs of a recovery we'll sometimes attend the installation
of a more rigid or less rigid discipline that you can't just,
you can't just go up or down.
The onset is in fact usually due to the collateral influence of an increased
confidence in the command whereby men are made to feel that their own fortunes
are on the mend.
Then discipline and morale are together revitalized almost as if by throwing in
electric switch in army history,
there's no better example of the working of this principle than the work of
Brigadier General Par Paul Be Malone.
He took over.
This is World War One 1919 he took over command where slackness and indiscipline
where general,
the men were suffering terrible privation and too many of their officers were
indifferent to their needs.
Many of them had been battle casualties.
Some had been discharged from hospitals before.
Their wounds were healed.
The mess was abominable.
The camp was short of firewood and other supply in freezing weather.
Men were sleeping on the ground with only a pair of blankets,
a piece.
The death toll from influenza,
pneumonia and the aggravation of battle wounds rose daily despair and resentment
over these conditions began to express itself in semi violent form.
Every fresh breath of discipline was countered with harassing punishments until
an air of wretched stagnation hung over the whole camp.
General Pershing visited the Bait,
the base the men refuse to form for him.
Then the men were off to the generals coming in.
The men,
we're not going to form up for him.
When he tried to address them at a mass meeting,
they wouldn't hear him out.
Instead of taking any action against the men he sent for General Malone,
the new commander arrived without any instructions except to determine what was
wrong and correct it with soldierly instinct.
He recognized that the indiscipline of the camp was an effect and not a cause,
but even as he gave orders for leaving the physical distress of the men,
he demanded that they returned to orderly habits.
He walked around the areas already on his ordered on his orders.
Duck boards were being laid throughout the mud and the whole physical setup was
in a process of reorganization.
The men grown listless from weeks of mysteries,
mistreatment paid.
No,
he'd get on your feet.
I'm your general,
I respect you but I want you respect where his words,
they restored the whole situation.
The first impact of this one man on the camp that was never forgotten by anyone
who saw it.
It is a point to remember a firm hold at the beginning pays 10 fold dividend of
the timid approach followed by a show of firmness.
Later on within 48 hours,
the physical condition of the camp was showing improvement and 60,000 men were
again doing their duty and bearing themselves in a military manner.
The lessons from this one incident stand out like beams from a search light
battery
leadership.
One man is able to accomplish a miracle by an act of will accompanied by good
works.
The morale of the force flows from self discipline of the commander and in turn
the discipline of the force is reestablished by the upsurge of its moral power.
Another example here when the redeployment period which followed World War II
threatened to complete collapse to the morale of the general military
establishment.
The remedy attempted by some unit leaders was to relax discipline and the work
requirement all around other officer's met this crisis by improving the
conditions of work,
setting an example which proved to the men that they believed in its importance
and paying such close attention to the personal problems of those within the
unit.
They found that they could still get superior performance in the midst of chaos.
Organic strength materializes in the same way on the field of war.
However,
adverse the general situation men will stick to the one man who knows what he
wants to do and welcomes them to a full share in the enterprise
leadership,
leadership and leadership most important thing on the battlefield
in the words of colonel g f r Henderson,
it is the leader who reckons with the human nature of his troops and of the
enemy rather than with their mere physical attributes.
Numbers are Mirman and the like.
Who can hope to follow in Napoleon's footsteps?
Got To know your people.
Got To know human nature.
God know human nature is more important than physical.
It's more important than people that you got,
number of people you've got.
It's more important than their weapons.
Human Nature.
There are a few governing principles and before considering their application in
detail,
we should first think about the file.
So now we're talking about a god troop,
a soldier.
He is a man.
He expects to be treated as an adult,
not a schoolboy.
He has rights.
They must be made known to him and thereafter respected.
Okay.
He has ambition.
It must be stirred.
He has a belief in fairplay.
It must be honored.
He has the need of comradeship.
It must be supplied.
He has imagination.
It must be stimulated.
He has a personal sense of dignity.
It must not be broken down.
He has pride.
It can be satisfied and made the bedrock of his character once he gains
assurance that he is playing a useful and respected part in a superior and
successful organization
to give men working as a group.
That feeling of great accomplishment together is the acme of inspired
leadership.
You could basically,
if you're going into a leadership position,
just read that to yourself every morning,
just what you,
what your subordinates are,
what they are a man.
Be Treated as an adult,
not a school boy.
Those are just
so important,
the way you view your troops.
And some people have a hard time with that.
So when people have a hard time with that.
Next section is called knowing your job
in one of the,
in one of his little known passages,
Robert Louis Stevenson.
Yeah,
that's the guy that wrote a doctor.
Jekyll and Mr. Hyde and treasure island did the perfect portrait of the man who
finally failed at everything because he just never learned how to take hold of
his work.
It goes like this.
His career was one of unbroken shame.
He did not drink.
He was exactly honest.
He was never rude to his employer's yet he was everywhere,
discharged,
bringing no interest to his duties.
He brought no attention.
His Day was a tissue of things neglected and things done.
A mess.
Okay.
And from place to place and from town to town.
He carried the character of one thoroughly incompetent.
That's how we started this conversation today and we started talking about doing
your job.
Now this is important just as a rough approximation,
any officer's work should comprise about 50% execution and the other half study
if he is to make the best use of his force,
the woods are loaded with go getters who claim they are men of action and
therefore have no need of books.
We're talking about studying what's the we're talking about,
we're talking about and studying and these guys that say that there's no need
for books.
They are of the same bone and marrow as the drone who is always counseling half
speed.
Don't sweat.
Just get by.
Extra work means short life,
you're better off if they don't notice you.
This chat can be heard by anyone who cares to listen.
It's the old American invitation to mediocrity,
but not all wisdom is to be found in books and at no time is this more true than
one when one is breaking in.
What is expected of any novice in any field is that he will ask questions,
smart ones if possible,
but if not,
then questions of all kinds until he learns that there is no such item as
Reveley oil.
And that skirmish line doesn't come on spools.
So Reveley oil revenues,
when you wake up in the morning,
it's that an Reveley oil is something that doesn't actually exist,
but you'd say to a new guy,
hey,
we need to get some revenue oils for tomorrow.
Can you go down to supply and get it for me?
Or skirmish line of skirmish line is when you get online to engage the enemy,
you don't mind in put your guns in the same direction.
That's called a skirmish line.
Well,
he said,
hey,
we need a spool,
a skirmish line.
Could Echo,
can you run down to the supply department and get us as a role of skirmish line?
So you know,
just kind of like little practical jokes,
but his point is here and people ask me this,
them where you will.
I just checked in and I'm just taking over as leader.
I'm just,
I'm a new officer.
I'm getting commissioned.
What should I do?
How should I lead?
Ask questions.
There's nothing wrong with it.
Back to the book,
wisdom begins at the point of understanding that there is nothing shameful about
ignorance.
It is shameful only when a man would rather remain in that state than
cultivating other men's knowledge.
Boom.
There's never any reason why you should hesitate for it is better to be
embarrassed from seeking counsel than to be found short for not having sought
it.
Ideally,
any officers should be able to do the work of any man under him.
However,
it is obviously absurd to expect that any officer could know more about radio
repair than his repairman.
More about mapping then as Carter Carter garage goal section.
More about moving parts that are gunsmith more about radar that a specialist in
electronics and more about cipher than a cryptographer.
The distinction lies in the difference between the power to do a thing well and
that of being able to judge when it is done well.
A man can say a book is bad though.
Not knowing how to write one himself.
Provided he is a student of literature though he has never laid an egg.
You can pass fair on an
Omelet.
So this is another thing,
you know you're knocked the know everything.
As a leader,
you know that I know as much about sniper sniping as my snipers didn't even know
clothes.
No heart.
You know that I know as much about it.
Just like he said,
I'm not as much about the radios.
Is My radio mended?
No,
no.
Close to what they knew.
You don't need to know everything,
but you have to have an understanding of it and you have to at least be able to
understand when something is being done right or wrong.
This is another good point.
We can ponder the words of William Hazlitt,
a man who's shrinks from a collision with his equals or superiors will soon sink
below himself.
We improve by trying our strength with others,
not by showing it off.
Okay,
so you can't be afraid to bring stuff up to your superiors.
Do you gotta be respectful?
Yes you do.
But instead of just being a yes man,
don't be that.
Now this next section,
yeah,
scald writing and speaking,
all other things being equal,
a superior rating will invariably be given to the officer who is preserved in
his studies of the art of self expression.
While his colleague who attaches little importance to what may be achieved
through working with the language will be marked for mediocrity.
So we're talking about reading and speaking,
writing and speaking
as the British statesmen Disraeli put it,
men govern with words within the military.
Establishment Command is exercised through what is set,
which commands attention and understanding and through what is a written which
directs,
explains,
interprets or informs battles are won through the ability of men to express
concrete ideas in clear and unmistakable language.
Battles are won through clear and unmistakable language.
That's how battles were won back to the book.
All administration is carried forward along the chain of command by the power of
men to make their thoughts articulate and available to others.
There is no way under the sun that this basic condition can be altered once the
point is granted,
any officer should be ready to accept its corollary.
That superior qualification in the use of language,
both as to the written and the spoken word is more essential to military
leadership.
The knowledge of the whole technique of weapons handling.
So when people ask me why I studied English in college,
this is why I studied English in college.
Okay?
Some men will take refuge in the excuse offered by the great majority.
I'm just a simple fighting file with no gift for writing or speaking.
That is the mark of an officer who has no ambition to properly qualify himself
and is seeking to justify his own laziness.
And the reason he's saying that is because he thinks that you can become a good
writer back to the book writers are self made,
but it is a reasonable speculation that history might never have heard of.
The greater number of these men had they not work,
said jealously to become proficient with the pen as well as with the sword.
Okay?
Men who command words to serve their thoughts and feelings are well on their way
to commanding men to serve their purposes.
All senior commanders respect the junior who has a faculty for thinking an idea
through and then expressing it comprehensively and clear unvarnished phases.
So you're young,
young leader out there,
young trooper.
Think about improving your method of fault.
Think about making your speech more clear.
Any man who has the brain to qualify for commission can make of himself a
competent writer because of natural limitations.
He may never excel in this art,
but if he has had average schooling,
knows how to open a dictionary,
can find his way to the library and is willing to commit himself to long study
and practice,
particularly in non duty hours.
And we'll finally free himself from the superstition that writing is a game only
for specialists.
He can acquire all the skill that is necessary to further his advanced within
the military profession.
But where should work begin?
How about a little practical advice?
The only way to learn to write is to write.
That's it.
There is no other secret other than hard,
unremitting practice.
Most writers at the start are mentally muscle bound and poorly coordinated bath
thoughts in their head.
They can,
they think they can develop them clearly,
but when they tried to apply,
I'll largely dormant vocabulary to the expression of these thoughts.
The result is stiff and self conscience self-conscious.
The only cure for this is constant mental exercise with one's pen or over one's
typewriter.
Yeah,
the discipline through which one learns to write,
add substance to thought whereby one's ideas are given body and connection.
Such common faults as worriness overstatement,
faulty sentence structure and week use of words are gradually corrected with
their passing confidence grows.
This does not mean however,
that the task becomes easy so you can get better at this game.
You just gotta practice kind of like getting better at pull ups.
I get it better at pull ups.
Pull ups.
Now this is interesting.
Speaking of a reading and or speaking of writing,
now we're getting into reading a little bit here.
This is good.
It is a good habit to underscore passages and books which have contributed
something vital to one's own fought.
So break out the highlighters.
I kind of laughed when I read that because I have a lot of highlighters and I
use them all.
Thank you.
Went Winchester on a couple of that idea.
That's right.
Now this is talking to going back to writing again.
As a practical matter is better to concentrate on a few elementary rules of
thumb such as are contained in the following list than to bog down attempting to
heed everything that the pendants have said about how to become a writer.
So here's some advice on writing and you'll notice that these are good advice on
life.
The more simply a thing is said,
the more powerfully it influences those who read plain words make strong
writing.
There is always one best word to convey a thought or a feeling to accept a
weaker substitute rather than to search for the right word will deprive any
writing of force.
Economy of words invigorates composition
and all writing.
But in military writing particularly,
there is no excuse for vague terminology or phrases which do not convey an exact
expression of what was done or what is intended and just think about how you
communicate with your subordinates and think about these rules.
So impactful.
This is a good one.
It is better at all times to reign in the strength of military writing like the
soundness of military operations does not gain through overstatement and
artificial coloring.
The bigger the subject,
the less it needs embroidery.
Now he's going to start talking here.
Go from talking about writing to talk about speaking.
A majority of the world's most gifted writers would in all probability be dumb
struck if put before an audience though dealing confidently with ideas.
They lacked the confidence when dealing with people.
The military officer has need of both talents and as to where the accent should
be placed.
It is probably more important that he should speak well.
Then his writing prose should be polished.
A unit commander may permit a clerk or a subordinate to do the greater part of
his paperwork either because his own time is taken with other duties are because
he is awkward at it.
But if he permits any other voice to dominate the councils of the organization,
he soon ceases to exercise moral authority over it.
So you got to be confident in your speaking a little bit more important than the
writing.
Cause you can have your guys do some writing.
Get the apple,
I'll sign it.
Looks good to me.
This guy,
uh,
one of the bosses I had both of that.
Oh so he'd always misused words like almost to the point where you know how some
comedians will do that.
They'll miss you.
Like [inaudible] does that a lot of time,
but yeah,
by this guy would for real do it.
Cause he didn't,
but you know what it was is you know how the King Guy who's,
they want to try to sound smart basically and not a good idea.
So he would use the word like irreguardless.
He would say it regardless as opposed to regardless.
And then there's another one that,
it's so funny because it's so counterproductive because when he would talk and
we'd all be holding in our laughter,
and I had worked with this other guy,
he was the king,
got relentless jokes,
you know,
when you're gone.
So if you did something,
and in this case you'd misused words when he leaves,
brother jokes would come in,
he'd be just so funny.
But nonetheless,
he would use,
um,
be hoof,
you know,
be who like it would be who.
Yeah,
I think it is.
Behoof oh,
you're right behind.
That's what I thought.
Anyway.
I though that's a whole nother thing.
But anyway,
behoove then,
so he would misuse that word.
He would,
he thought it meant what he thought it meant baffling.
Like,
Oh,
you know,
what really behooves me is that they do it this way and then he,
but he keep doing it,
you know,
and um,
so anyway,
the point there is where you Kinda,
you gotta know how to talk.
Right?
So,
okay.
And in this case,
this was,
this wasn't like some high level like speeches he was making or address.
It was just like normal stuff.
So bright.
I thought that that was kind of critical in the way.
Like we regarded him as a,
that was one of the meat,
like major things where it's like,
Bro,
we can't even take this guy seriously.
Yeah.
Cause he,
he behooves me with everything.
Oh Lord.
Wrong usage.
It's okay.
People,
yeah it was not okay.
I guess the point there,
a Norris separate point is learn the words before you start trying to throw him
out I guess.
And that goes back to what you're saying.
That would be very,
yeah,
that'd be who,
what you were saying about,
um,
uh,
it's better to seek then or be seek the knowledge and be embarrassed cause you
gotta seek rather than get it
called out when you don't know it or whatever.
Anyway.
Yeah.
That's what he was doing
back to the book.
The matter of nerve is a main element in speaking when an officer's ill at ease,
fidgety and not to the point,
the vote of his command for the time being is no confidence.
Okay.
And so long as he remains that way,
they will not change.
No matter though,
his goodwill shines forth through in other acts,
so it says what you just said.
Someone's jacked up when they're trying to talk to you and talk to the group.
You're,
your vote is no confidence.
Yeah.
That's a comfortable road
as this is a good good.
Back to the book.
As for how an officer to talk to his men,
his manner and tone should be no different than if you were addressing his
fellow officers or for that matter,
a group is the intellectual and political peers from any walk of life.
If he is stuffy,
he will not succeed.
If he affects a superior manner,
that is a mark of his inferiority.
If he is patronizing and talks to grown men as a teacher might talk to a class
of adolescence,
the rug figuratively will be pulled out from under him.
His audience,
where we put down,
we'll put him down as a chump,
is curiously the case that the junior officer who can't get the right pitch when
he talks to the ranks will also be out of tune.
When he talks to his superiors,
this failing is a sign mainly that he needs practice in the school of human
nature.
By listening a little more carefully to other men,
he may find he may himself in time attain maturity.
Another good way to get better at speaking is by listening.
No doubt
when you're speaking,
sometimes you're instructing.
And one of the,
one of the pieces here is called the art of instruction.
Okay?
Because you spent so much time when you're in a leadership position,
you're instructing people whether you realize or not,
you're instructing people,
here's the rules that they say to follow.
Keep it simple.
Have but one main object.
Stay on the course,
remain cheerful,
be enthusiastic,
put it out as if the ideas were as interesting and novel to you as to your
audience.
Now this is a story which really dawn on,
you know,
it has to do with instruction,
but it's cool story.
So I'm gonna read it anyways because it's just bad ass in World War One and
American major name.
Now long forgotten was given the task of making the realms and talking to all
combat formations and convincing them that the future was bright.
No boy scout errands.
So you mentioned new World War One,
we've talked about that it's a nightmare and he's his is to go around and ensure
people that the future's bright,
but wherever he went,
morale was lifted by his words.
It's substance in substance.
What he said was this [inaudible]
none of us cares about making a living with any individuals who wants every
break his own way.
But when the odds are even to gamble is worth any good man's time.
So let's look at the proportion.
You now have one chance in two.
You may go overseas or you may not.
Suppose you do.
You still have one chance in two.
You may go to the front or you may not.
If you don't,
you'll see a foreign country at Uncle Sam's expense.
If you do,
you'll find out about war,
which is the toughest chance of the mall.
But up there on the front,
you still have one chance.
In two you may get hit or you may not.
If you breeze through it,
you'll be a better man for all the rest of your life.
And if you get hit,
you still have one chance in two,
you may get a small wound and become a hero to your friends and family,
or there was always the last chance that it may take you out all together.
And while that is a little rugged,
it is at least worth remembering that very few people seem to get out of this
life alive.
Classic classic.
Okay.
Now,
talking about reading,
Napoleon once said that the point that the trouble with books is that one must
read so many bad ones to find something really good,
true enough.
But even so,
there are perfectly practical ways to advance rapidly without undue wasted
motion.
Consider this among one superiors.
There were always discriminating men who have adopted a few good books after
reading many,
many bad ones.
When they say that a text is worthwhile,
it deserves reading and careful study.
So what books did somebody you respect,
read?
They say it's a good book.
Read it now you gotta be careful because,
yeah,
because of this,
the well-read man need not have more than a dozen books in his home provided
that they all count with him and he continues to pour over them and ponder the
weight of what is said.
On the other hand,
the ignorant man is frequently marked by his bookshelf stocked with titles,
not one of which suggests that he has any professional discernment.
Now,
I can tell you right now,
I'm building a library of books.
That's kind of crazy.
Um,
because every time somebody calls,
every time somebody hits me up on social media and says,
hey,
you gotta check out this pocket,
I used to like go on Amazon and kind of look read reviews.
Now I just order
it,
right?
I mean,
it basically order it because I don't have time and it's hard to tell from the
reviews and it takes much time.
It's easier just to press,
click,
buy.
Now Amazon,
I'm clicking through the Jocko podcast store website.
So we're,
we're giving back to the,
to the,
uh,
to the podcast.
But the thing is,
a lot of people might think this book is great,
all of this would be a great book,
but it doesn't quite work,
you know?
So I'm probably getting,
I'd say one out of every five books that I ordered,
do I say,
yeah,
this one's this one's game.
Yeah.
What he's saying there about,
um,
the difference between somebody who has a huge stock of books,
is he seeing like a variety variety of different books that doesn't end.
It said something about not indicating any kind of expertise or something just
says he did.
It just shows that he doesn't have any discernment.
This guy just buying or much of books and might not know anything about them.
It doesn't mean it.
Don't judge a book by its cover,
Pun intended,
you know,
just cause this guy's got a bunch of books,
doesn't mean that he's read them all.
Doesn't mean that he actually,
oh,
they're all great books really.
I can tell you right now.
And they're an all great books in the world.
Yeah.
A lot of books are not good and you shouldn't waste your time reading them.
But if I,
if you walked into a guy that was smart that you respect,
he get 12 bucks.
Right?
Right.
I would just write them all down and go buy them all.
And you're probably going to be 10 for 12 for 12.
Yeah.
Or at least 10 for 12.
Whereas if I go into your room and you've got 570 bucks in there and go,
yeah,
these are all great books.
There's something wrong with your discernment.
You don't know what a good book is.
Yeah.
So get some discernment or I'm just trying to make,
like I read so much to the length of life,
uh,
this,
this section,
your relationships with your men.
Okay.
And I had to break,
I had to say this park and officer's not expected to appear all wise to those
who serve under him.
So often guys feel that pressure that they think should,
they should know everything.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
No.
If I admit that I don't know this,
I'm going to look bad.
Bluffing one's way through a question.
When ignorant of the answer is foolhardy business.
I'm sorry,
but I don't know.
It's just as appropriate from an officer's lips.
It's from any other and it helps a little more to add,
but I'll find out.
Rank should be used to serve one subordinates.
It should never be flaunted or used to get the upper hand of a subordinate.
Any situation save where he is already discredited himself in an unusually ugly
or unseemingly manner.
When suggestions from any subordinate or adopted,
the credit should be passed on to him publicly.
When a subordinate made a mistake but not from any lack of goodwill,
it is common sense to take the rap for him rather than make him suffer doubly
for his error and officer should not issue orders which he cannot enforce.
He should be as good as his word at all times and in any circumstance he should
promise nothing which he cannot make stick and officer should not work.
Looking over his men shoulders,
checking on every detail of what they're doing and calling them to account at
every for long past
this mainly Lee attitude corrodes confidence and destroys initiatives that don't
micromanage.
On the other hand,
contact is necessary at all times,
particularly when men are doing long term work or operating in a detachment.
At a remote point,
they will become discouraged and we'll lose their sense of direction unless
they're superior.
Looks in on them.
Periodically ask them whether he can be of any help and so doing gets them to
open up the discussion and the problem.
The navy says,
this is another good,
another good one right here.
The navy says it isn't courtesy to change the set of the sail within 30 minutes
after the relief of watch applied to command job.
This means that is a mistake for an officer on taking a new post to order
sweeping changes affecting the other men in the belief that this will give him a
reputation for action and firmness.
The studying of the situation is the overture of the steadying of it.
Okay?
The story is told of General Curtis Lemay of the Air Force taking over the 21st
bomber command and in the Mariana's he faced the worried staff officers of his
predecessor and said,
quietly,
you're all staying put.
I assume you know your jobs or you wouldn't be here.
Pretty simple.
Then people always ask,
come into Neil,
what do I do when I take over?
Relax,
be humble,
listen,
observe.
Don't need to jump in there and change the set of the sail or an echo is gone.
Now I'm in charge.
Change everything.
No wrong answer.
This next section,
your men's morale,
moral and physical welfare.
When men are moral,
the moral power which binds them together and fits them for high action is given
its main chance for success.
Now listen to these to be temperate in all things,
to be continent and refrain from loose living of any sort are acts of the will.
They require self denial and the foregoing of that,
which may be more attractive in favor of the thing which should be done.
Okay.
Granted there are a few individuals who are so thin blooded that they never feel
tempted to digress morally.
Men and mud,
the majority are not like that.
So there's some guys that just on the straight narrow,
they're so,
they're so thin blooded that they just,
they get no temptations.
Most men,
they get temptations.
What they were announcing,
the name of self discipline at the cost of the considerably and considerable
inner.
They endeavor to compensate by gains in their personal character.
Making that grade isn't easy,
but no one who is anyone has yet said that it isn't worthwhile in the armed
services.
They're an old saying that an officer without character is more useless than a
ship with no bottom.
In summing up,
the strength of will,
which enables a man to lead a clean life is no different than the strength of
purpose,
which fits him to follow a hard line of duty.
There are exceptions to every rule.
Many a lovable rounder has proved himself to be a first class fighting man.
But even though he had an uncomparable unconquerable weakness for drinking,
women has resolution had to become steeled along some other line or we would
have been no good when the pay off came.
So this is,
you know,
saying that the strength of will that it takes to stay strong and all of these
situations,
all these temptations that that will,
is,
is real and that can transfer over it.
Now I can tell you that this one is,
you know,
there's all the military is filled.
Like he says,
many of lovable rounders proved himself to be a first class.
What I mean of course guys,
they're bad ass guys throughout the ages that were why even Henry the fifth,
I don't wild man reputation going back to Shakespeare
and so,
but he's saying that you know these,
these
staying on the straight and narrow enforces your will is what he's saying.
Back to the book,
putting aside for the moment,
the question of the vices and regarding only the game to moral power,
which comes of bodily exercise and physical conditions.
So he's talked about vices.
Okay,
we got it.
Stay clean,
stay clean is what he's saying.
But now he's saying there's something else.
There's something called exercise and physical conditioning.
It should be self evident that the process which builds the muscle must also
train in alert the mind.
How could it be otherwise?
Every physical act must have as its origin,
a mental impulse,
conscious or unconscious.
Thus in training a man to master his muscles,
we also help him to master his brain.
He comes out of physical training,
not only better condition to move,
but better prepared to think about how and why he is moving,
which is true mobility.
So you want to strengthen your will.
Yes,
stay clean,
stay on the moral path,
and then get your physical conditioning on because that's gonna make you
mentally tougher.
Back to the book in the United States Service,
we are tending to forget because of the effect of motorization at the higher
value of the discipline of the road.
March in other days,
wasn't that it hearted the muscles,
but that short of combat,
it was the best method of separating the men from the boys.
This is true today,
despite all the new conditions imposed by technological changes are hard.
Road March is the most satisfactory training test of the moral strength of the
individual man.
At the same time to census the overload men for road marching hurts them in two
ways,
dichotomy to everything so you can hurt them with a road march.
Here's the two ways.
Eight weakens their faith in the sense of the command,
thereby impairing morale and it breaks down their muscle and tendons.
So you overload them.
You're going to crush them,
you're going to break them,
you're going to ruin their spirit.
There is another not infrequent cause of breakdown.
The leader who makes the mistake of thinking that every man's limit is the same
as his own.
So you,
oh,
I can,
I can do this.
I can hump in 20 miles or 20 clicks.
Everyone can do it.
Wrong answer.
When an officer does this kind of thing thoughtlessly he shows himself to be an
incompetent observer of men.
When he does it to show off,
he deserves to be given 10 days in the electric chair.
Hey,
there you go.
Getting the electric chair 10 days.
That's a,
that's like how many times do you die in 10 days in the electric chair or know a
lot,
but don't show off is the point.
Yeah.
Otherwise you're going in the electric chair for 10 days,
but isn't that like an old classic thing in the movie where it's usually to like
combat like a situation where the guys are complaining,
you know,
like all of this,
do I this unrealistic,
I don't know.
Obstacle course.
Yeah,
they're like this.
And then the drill sergeant or whoever he,
he does it.
You know,
he's like the older guy.
Well yeah,
he's proving that,
look,
I'm not asking you to do anything that I wouldn't do myself.
Yeah.
That's all that that is.
Right.
But in a way he's like,
Hey,
I can do it.
So you should be able to do it.
That's true.
Guess what?
A young recruit should be able to do it.
Otherwise it's not reaching the standards.
You've got to have standards.
Yeah.
But if he was saying,
hey,
you should be able to do this with one arm tied behind your back,
like I can,
cause that could be wrong.
Yeah.
You see the difference sir?
Well,
yeah,
cause it makes sure because otherwise you can get me on a technicality.
Don't want that to happen over here.
Speaking of athletic accomplishments in the nature of things,
the officer who's been an athlete can fit himself into this part of the program
with little difficulty and with great credit provided he acts with moderation
that adhere as suggested.
By the same token,
the officer who is shown sports in school,
either because he didn't have the size or coordination or is more interested in
something else,
we'll frequently have an understandable hesitation about trying to play the lead
hand in anything which he thinks will make him look bad.
Just talking about the benefits of the sports.
Hmm.
If he has not kept himself in good physical shape,
his nerves will not be able to stand the strain of combat to say nothing of his
legs.
It can be said again and again.
The highest form of physical training that an officer can undergo is the
physical conditioning of his own men.
Nothing else can give him more faith in his own ability to stay the course and
nothing else is likely to give him a firmer feeling of solidarity with his men
study and an active thirst for wider professional knowledge have their place in
an officer's scheme of thing things.
But there is something about the experience of bodily competition of joining
with and leading men and strenuous physical exercise,
which uniquely invigorates one spirit with the confidence.
I can do this.
I can lead,
I can command
the body and mind are connected everybody.
No it
back to the book.
The really good thing about the gain and moral force deriving from all forms of
physical training is that it is an unconscious gain,
willpower,
determination,
mental poise and muscle control all march hand in hand with the general health
and wellbeing of the man with results,
not less decisive under training conditions.
Then on the field of battle,
a man who develops correct posture and begins to fill out his body so that he
looks the part of a fighter of will take greater pride in wearing the uniform.
In doing so,
he will take greater care to conduct himself morally that he will not disgrace
it.
He will gain confidence as he acquires like a confident and determined bearing.
This same presence and the physical strength which contributes to it will help
carry him through the hour of danger.
Strength of will is partly of the mind and partly of the body in combat.
Fatigue will beat down men as quickly as any other condition for fatigue
inevitably carries fear with it.
Tired.
Men are afraid.
Yeah,
there is no quicker way to lose a battle than to lose it on the road.
For lack of preliminary hardening in troops.
Such a condition cannot be redeemed by the resolve of a commander who insists on
driving troops and extra mile beyond their general level of physical endurance.
So,
so if you got guys that aren't ready,
just cause you're fired up doesn't mean it's going to work.
You can't push them hard.
Now here's what happens.
Extremes of this sort make men rebellious and hateful of the command and thus
strike at tactical efficiency from two directions at
for when men resent to commander,
they will not fight as willingly for him and when their bodies are spent,
their nerves are gone.
Physical conditioning.
Now on top of that,
we got the physical addition and you also have to keep your people informed in
war.
In the absence of information man's natural promptings,
alternate between unreasoning fears that the worst is likely to happen and the
wishful thought that all danger is remote.
Either impulse is a barrier to the growth of that condition of alert confidence
which comes to men when they have a realization of their own strength and a
reasonably clear concept of the general situation.
You got to keep your people in form.
That's what I was talking about earlier being at the end of a platoon.
Next section is about counseling your men.
Nothing more unfortunate can happen to an officer then to come to be regarded by
his subordinates,
says unapproachable for such a reputation isolates him from the main problems of
the command responsibility as well as its chief rewards.
How do you become approachable?
The two formal manner,
the over rigid attitude,
the disposition to deal with any human problem by the numbers as if it were one
more act in an organizational routine can have a chilling effect upon men so
that that idea that you're just going to be by the book on everything,
that's not going to make you approachable.
That being said back to the book,
it is not necessary that an officer,
wet nurses,
men in order to serve well in the role of counsel,
his doors should be open,
but he's not play the part either of father confessor or of a hotel greeter,
neither great psalm knee or a few snus or called for,
but mainly serious attention to the problem and then straight forward advice or
decision according to the nature of the case and provided that from his own
knowledge and experience he feels qualified to give it.
If not,
it is wiser to differ then to offer a half baked opinion.
That's okay.
If you don't know,
hey,
look,
I don't really,
I've never dealt with this before.
Maybe you should go talk to echo.
He deals with these computers all the time.
Come to me with your computer problems.
Back to the book of World War,
two officers had to abide by this standard dealing with the general malaise
which rose out of redeployment.
Okay.
When a man came forward and said that he couldn't take it anymore and the
commander knew that he'd always been a highly dutiful individual.
It became the commander's job to attempt to get the home.
But when a second man came forward with the same story and the record showed
that he'd always shirked his work,
the question was whether he should be given the final chance to shirk it again.
Okay.
To favor the first man meant furthering discipline,
his comrades recognize that as a fear deal to turn back.
The second man was equally constructive to the same end.
So those are,
that's just classic and we've seen that in just about every book we read you and
with some Guy World War II or we saw a bunch of it.
If some guy would just lose it and we've installed the Korean,
you know some of the Korean books we've covered,
the guy loses it,
but there are a good guy.
Remember the guy walking around in his sleeping bag?
Look,
we're just going to take care of this guy.
He's been a good guy.
We'll get him off the front.
He's got a few days left,
but then when you get a guy that's that's a weak and scared and doesn't man up
and do his duty at any wants to go home,
they're not given that got slack,
doesn't deserve it.
Didn't earn it.
Hmm.
Now,
this is interesting.
There are officers who hold every subordinate like grim death.
See no better way to advance their personal fortunes.
So this is what we're talking about here is,
and this happens a lot in the military,
what it happens in every business I work with,
where you've got people that are being moved around,
so like,
oh,
echo works.
You've got this guy Billy that works for you.
Hey,
I need Billy to help me with this project.
What do you say?
No,
you can't have him.
He's my guy.
What?
What do you have more working on right now?
I've got some projects coming up.
I need him right now.
You know what I'm saying?
So people go into that mode where they hold everyone like a grim death.
There are officers who hold every able subordinate like grim death scene.
No better way to advance their personal fortunes.
This is a sign of moral weakness,
not have strength,
and it is inevitable fruit and it's inevitable.
Fruit is discontent within the organization.
The sign of superiority in any officer at whatever level is his confidence that
he can make another good man to fill any vacancy.
Okay.
The other time I don't like that is when somebody,
you know,
if you're gonna give me Billy and it's actually your promotion for Billy,
it's like a step up,
but you don't want to give them to me anyways,
you're,
you're hurting him because you're just trying to help yourself.
Yeah.
No.
Give a guy up.
Find somebody else new.
Find a better person.
Find some,
it's going to mold and make better.
Yeah.
I had that happened to me before you,
the guy,
were you the guy,
the guy that got,
didn't get promoted.
Correct.
Somebody held onto you.
Yeah.
And it was less about if I did or didn't get promoted,
it was that he was just holding on where you know,
to kind of negate any chance of that.
He was clear.
He actually even told me too.
Well,
that was at least straight forward on them.
Yeah,
not good.
How'd that work out for you,
for your morale?
It didn't help it daily.
Okay.
Back to the book.
Some the ablest commanders
in our service have abided by this rule.
They never denied the man who had a legitimate reason for transfer and they
never shuffled off their lemons and gold bricks under a false label,
so that does another thing that happens in businesses.
Hey,
you've got Billy,
he bill,
he's a bum,
and I say,
Hey,
echo,
I need a guy over here to help me with us.
Oh yeah,
you can have Billy,
great guy.
You give me a bill.
He's a disaster as a gold brick.
It's a lie.
Here's a few common sense rules which when followed will enable any officer to
play as part more effectively in the counseling of men and access of expression
is a failing.
So when you give away your facial expression looks all that's a failing
to listen well is the prelude toward pondering carefully and speaking wisely?
Listen,
got to listen.
To refuse with kindness is more winning.
Then to acquiesce ungraciously.
That's a good one.
Just ain't know what I don't think it's going to be rather than all right.
Yeah.
That's like something you've got to deal with with your wife.
No.
Your wife wants to go do something new.
You'd be better to say,
you know what I'm thinking about?
That's not do that tonight.
Let's do,
let's do this other thing instead as opposed to,
all right,
fine.
We'll go to your friend's house.
Don't want to do that.
Didn't act like a dick when you get there.
To note another man's mood and become congenial to it is the surest way to
engage is competence.
Decisions which are wholly of the heart and not of the mind will ultimately do
hurt to both places.
Use your logic.
Don't get emotional.
No Man.
We'll talk freely if met by silence,
but an intelligent question encourages frankness above all else.
When a man loses possession of himself,
it is the more reason that the other should tighten his reserve.
Legit.
This is a good one to express.
Pity for a man does not serve to restore him and put him above pity.
When a man is so burdened by a personal problem that it shuts out all else,
he must be led to something else
and the last one here in prudent tactics can undo the wisest strategy and that
happens at every level.
It happens in war,
it happens in business.
You've got a great strategy,
but the guys on the ground are really not doing it tactically well.
It doesn't matter the strategy you're going to fail.
Finally in counseling like all else and military life has a combat purpose.
Other things being equal,
the tactical unity of men working together in combat will be in ratio to their
knowledge and sympathetic understanding of each other.
Whatever the cause,
aloofness on the part of the officer can only produce a further withdraw on that
part of the man
aloofness.
Now,
the last section of this book
was really devastating on my highlighter.
It's called Americans in combat,
okay?
The command and control of men in combat can be mastered by junior leaders of
American forces,
short of an actual experience under enemy fire.
It is altogether possible for a young officer his first time in battle to be in
total possession of his faculties and moving by instinct to do the right thing.
Provided that he has made the most of his training opportunities
exercise in the maneuvering of men is only an elementary introduction to this
educational process.
The basic requirement is a continuing study,
first of the nature of men.
Second of the techniques which produce unified action and last of the history of
past operations which are covered by an abundant literature.
That's how you got to get ready for combat.
Those things right there.
Now there are a few simple and fundamental propositions which the armed services
subscribe insane to officer corps what may be expected of the average man of the
United States under battle conditions.
Generally speaking,
they have held true of Americans in times past.
From Lexington to Okinawa,
the fighting establishment builds it's disciplined training,
code of conduct and public policy around these ideas.
Believing that what served yesterday will also be the one best way tomorrow and
for so long as our traditions and our system of freedom survives,
these propositions are
when lead with courage and intelligence and American will fight as willingly as
and as efficiently as any fighter in world history.
I concur with that.
His keenness and endurance in war will be in proportion to the zeal and
inspiration of his leadership.
Yeah,
he is resourceful and imaginative,
imaginative,
and the best results will always flow from encouraging him to use his brain
along with his spirit.
Under combat conditions.
He will reserve his greatest loyalty for the officer who is most resourceful in
the tactical employment of his forces and most careful to avoid unnecessary
losses.
So the the soldiers going to know if you're throwing bodies away,
they're going to know it.
And same thing in the business world.
I've worked with a lot of companies where they do their utmost to,
let's say there's a downturn in the market and they're going think that they're
going to fire some people and they do their best to mitigate that.
That develops loyalty,
that makes them fight harder when the market turns back around.
Now sometimes that can be a problem because people try and be so loyal that
they'd run their business in the ground.
They fail
back to the book,
except on a Hollywood lot.
There is no such thing as an American fighter type.
Our best month men come in all colors,
shapes,
and sizes.
They appear from every section of the nation,
including the territories.
Yeah.
In battle,
Americans do not tend to fluctuate between emotional extremes.
In complete dejection one day an XL Taishan the next according to the changes in
the situation,
they continue on the whole,
on a fairly even keel when the going is tough and when things are breaking their
way,
even when heavily shocked by battle losses,
they tend to bounce back quickly.
Okay.
Though they're griping is incessant.
They're natural.
Outlook is on the optimistic side and they react unfavorably to the officer who
looks eternally on the dark side.
Next during battle,
American officers are not expected either to drive their men or to be forever in
the van as if praying to be shot.
So the van is like on the front lines the front of your formation,
so long as they are with their men taking the same chances as their men and
showing a firm grasp of the situation and of the line of action which should be
followed.
The men will go forward
in any situation of extreme pressure or moral exhaustion where men cannot
otherwise be rallied and led forward.
Officers are expected to do the actual physical act of leading,
such as performing as first scout or point.
Even though this mean take means taking over what would normally be an enlisted
man's function.
The normal next,
the normal gregarious American is not at his best when playing alone handed or
tactically isolated part in battle.
He is not a kamikaze or a one man torpedo.
Consequently,
the best tactical results obtain from those dispositions and methods which link
the power of one to that of another.
Men who feel strange with their unit having been carelessly received by it and
indifferently handled will rarely if ever fight strongly and courageously.
But if treated with common decency and respect,
they will perform like men.
So that's just talking about when you check in somewhere,
you know,
you,
if you're in the military and you get somebody that checks and take care of
them,
welcome.
If you're at a company and somebody checks and take care of them,
Show him around a sign of a mentor.
Get them in the game.
Hmm
to lie to American troops to cover up a blundering.
Combat rarely serves any valid purpose.
They have a good sense of combat and an uncanny instinct for ferreting out the
truth.
When anything goes wrong.
Tactically,
they will excuse mistakes,
but they will not forgive being treated like children.
Basic leadership,
good one here.
When spit and Polish are laid on so heavily that they become onerous and the
ranks cannot see any legitimate connection between the requirements and the
development of an attitude which will serve a clear fighting purpose.
It is to be questioned that the exaction serve any good object,
whatever.
So again,
I'm a I,
I'm like leaning in the seal teams.
I'm probably the extreme level of,
of military bearing and uniformity.
But I'm definitely not a believer that,
you know,
you got everything,
every single thing spit and Polish all day long.
No.
Hmm.
And they're saying clearly here that if you go so far in that direction and
people don't make any sense of it,
it's not going to be good.
Yeah.
I mean even picture,
you know,
Hackworth was like Mr Spit and Polish,
look at pictures of Hackworth in Vietnam.
I mean you wouldn't even wear rank.
You know,
he looked like a regular soldier can look any exquisite parade.
Matter of fact,
he makes fun of the guys from the,
that come into the camp that looked like they're in parade ground uniforms.
Yeah.
I saw a quote,
it's like yesterday,
a spotless house is the sign of a wasted life.
Which when I saw it,
I tend to like,
I dunno,
disagree with a lot because it like,
it basically takes one kind of perspective and like makes it into this like
thing.
But if I like with this when I was like,
well,
or it means you clean your house all the time,
that's what you know.
Or maybe your discipline you have,
you know,
you clean your stuff including your house.
I don't know.
Maybe you take care of your house.
Maybe here as cleaning person,
that's not a wasted life by the way,
I think.
I think that's just an extreme statement,
but I think the underlying messages,
you know,
hey live a little is basically,
yeah.
In a way it's kind of the message there is kind of,
you're saying you,
if you take it literally,
yeah,
that could,
you could,
you could go too far down that road.
You can just take it as
okay.
A message.
I think the messages fairly clear and I somewhat agree with it,
you know?
Yeah.
Like you spent your whole life making sure everything in your house is clean.
You know,
they say also like the,
the Highly Polished Samurai sword that's never been used in battle is a lot less
valuable to me than the,
than the switch blade knife that's rusty from blood k Bar.
That's rusty from blood know.
Next one
on the other hand,
because standards of discipline and courtesy are designed for the express
purpose of furthering control under the extraordinary frictions.
Impressions of the battlefield.
They're maintenance under combat conditions is as necessary as during training.
Smartness and respect are the marks of military alertness,
no matter how trying the circumstances,
but courtesy starts at the top in the dealing of any officer with his
subordinates and then the decent regard for their loyalty,
intelligence and manhood.
So even though you can't be over disciplined,
you've still got to have the discipline.
Next though Americans enjoy relatively a bountiful and even luxurious standard
of living in their home environment.
They do not have to be pampered for spoon fed or overfilled with every comfort
and convenience to keep them steadfast and devoted.
Once war comes,
they are by nature rugged men and in the field they will respond most perfectly.
When called on to play a rugged part.
Soft handling will soften even the best men,
but even the week man,
we'll develop a new vigor and competence in the face of necessary hardship.
If moved by a leadership which is courageously making the best of a bad
situation,
it's just awesome.
Soft handling will soften even the best men and the weak man will come around
for a necessary hardship.
You notice they put that word in there NESAD not just beating him up for no
reason.
Yeah,
they got to see why it is.
Yup.
Next extravagance and wastefulness is somewhat rooted in the American character
because of our mode of life.
When our men enter the military service,
there's a strong holdover from their civilian habits.
Even under fighting conditions,
they tend to be wasteful of drinking water,
food munition,
and other vital supply.
When such things are made to accessible,
okay,
they tend to throw them away rather than conserve them.
In the general interests.
This is a distinct weakness during combat.
When conservation of all supplies a touchstone of success,
the regulating
of all supply and the preventing of waste in any form is the prime obligation of
every officer
be frugal.
Next,
under the conditions of battle,
any extra work,
exercise,
maneuver,
or marching,
which does not serve a clear and direct operational purpose is unjustifiable.
The supreme object is to keep men as physically fresh and mentally alert as
possible.
Tired men take fright and her half whipped before the battle opens.
Worn out.
Officers cannot make clear decisions.
The conservation of men's powers,
not the exhaustion thereof is a successful way of operations.
Next,
when forces are committed to combat,
it is vital that not one unnecessary pound be put on any man's.
Yeah,
back
lightness of foot is the key to speed of movement and the increase of fire
power.
In judging of these things,
every officer's thought should be on the optimistic side.
It is better to take the chance that men will manage to get by on a little less
than to overload them through overcautious reckoning of every possible
contingency,
thereby destroying their power to do anything effectively.
Every pound counts they used to,
when I was at a team too,
they had winter warfare platoons and so you'd be up burning calories on skis and
those guys were so anal about making their gear as light as possible.
It's pretty impressive.
So you know when you've got a backpack or something and it's got straps,
you know that you can loosen up or tighten up.
They would through the whole backpack that they would cut off.
Any excess strap would be gone just to get everything as light as possible.
It's kind of a good strategy to follow when you travel,
you know?
Yeah.
You know what the funny thing is too is I've got this now,
I've got this pretty down where I was like,
you know what?
If I buy,
if I don't have this,
if I don't bring this and I need it,
I'm just gonna buy it.
Right.
I'm going to go to a wherever and buy it,
no factor
because this kind of those two schools of thought,
whatever,
two ways to think about it where the person is like,
I might need it so I'm going to bring it and the other person is like,
if I can't think of a specific time that I'm going to need this on the Strip,
I'm not going to bring it and just like how you say it,
if I need it,
I'll buy it there.
Travel light freeze at night.
Yes.
All right.
Yeah,
yeah.
Talk to me that one before.
Next.
Unity of action develops from fullness of information in combat.
All ranks have to know what is being done and why it is being,
if confusion is to be kept to a minimum.
This holds true in all types of operations,
whatever the service,
however,
a surplus of inflammation clouds the mind and may sometimes depress the spirit.
We can take one example.
Commander might be confronted by a complex situation and his solution may be a
continuing operation in three distinct phases.
It would be advisable that all hands be told the complete detail of phase a,
but it might be equally sensible that his subordinates only his subordinates who
are closest to him be made fully informed about phase B and phase c.
All plans in combat are subject to modification as to circumstances dictate this
being the case,
it is not better.
It is better not to muddle the men by filling their minds with a seemingly
conflict of ideas or conflict in ideas.
More important still,
if the grand object seems too vast and formidable,
even the first step toward it may be a pure doubly difficult fullness of
information does not void the other principle that one thing at a time carefully
organized all down the line is the surest way prioritize and execute.
There is no next,
there is no excuse for malingering or cowardice during battle is the task of
leadership.
To stop it by whatever means would seem to be the surest cure,
always making certain that in doing so,
it will not make a matter of
worse.
Next.
The armed services recognize that there are occasional individuals who nervous
and spiritual makeup may be such that they erode rapidly and may suffer complete
breakdown under combat conditions.
They still may be wholly loyal and conscientious men capable of doing duty
elsewhere.
Men are not alike in some,
however willing the spirit,
the flesh may be too weak to punish,
degrade,
or in any way humiliate such men is not more cruel than ignorant when the good
faith of any individual has been repeatedly demonstrated earlier service.
He deserves the benefit of the doubt from his superior pending study of his case
by medical authority.
But if the man has been a bad actor,
consistently has officers warranted in proceeding on the assumption that has
combat failure.
Just one more grave moral dereliction to fail to take proper action against such
a man can only work on usual hardship on the majority trying to do the duty
next,
the United States abides by the laws of war.
It's armed forces in dealing with in their dealings with all other peoples are
expected to comply with the laws of war in the spirit and to the letter in
waging war we do not terrorize helpless noncombatants if it is within our power
to avoid doing so.
Wanting killing,
torture,
cruelty or the working of unusual and unnecessary hardship on enemy prisoners or
populations is not justified under any circumstance like wise respect for the
reign of law as that term is understood by the United States is expected to
follow the flag wherever it goes.
Pillaging,
looting and other excesses are as a moral,
as unmoral where Americans are operating under military law as they are living
together under civil code.
Nonetheless,
some men in the American services will loot and destroy properly unless they are
restrained by fear of punishment.
War looses violence and disorder.
It inflames passions in makes it relatively easy for the individual to get away
with unlawful actions,
but it does not lessen the gravity of his offense or make it less necessary.
That constituted authority put him down.
Okay.
The main safeguard against lawlessness and hooliganism in any armed body is the
integrity of its officers.
When men know that their commander is absolutely opposed to sus such excesses
and we'll take forceful action to repress any breach of discipline,
they will conform.
But when an officer winks at any degradation by his men,
it is no different than if he had committed the act.
Remember that one young leaders out there on the battlefield,
but an officer winks at any degradation of his men.
It no different than if he'd committed the act and if you hold the discipline,
if you call the discipline,
they will conform.
If they know where you fall,
where you stand,
I should say,
if they know where you stand,
they will conform.
Next on the field of sport,
Americans always talking up to keep nerve steady and degenerate.
Confidence the need is even greater on the field of war and the same treatment
will have no less effect.
When men are afraid they go silent.
Silence of itself further intensifies the fear.
The resumption of speech is the beginning of thoughtful,
collected action for self.
Evidently two or more men cannot join strength and work intelligently together
until they know one another's thoughts.
Consequently,
all training is an exercise in getting men to open up and become articulate,
articulate,
even as it is a process in conditioning them physically to move strongly
together.
Once again,
step in,
even talking is action.
That starts to dispel fear.
Hmm.
Next inspection is more important in the face of the enemy.
Then during training,
because a found piece of fouled piece may mean a lost battle and overlooked.
Sick man may infect a fortress and a mislaid message can cost a war.
In virtue of his position,
every junior leader is an inspector and the obligation to make certain that his
force at all times is inspection proof is unremitting.
Then the last one,
I'm going to read the close out this book.
It's clear in battle crisis for majority of Americans present,
present will respond to any man who has the will and the brains to give them a
clear,
intelligent order.
They will follow the lowest ranking man present if he obviously knows what he's
doing and is morally the master of the situation.
But they will not obey a chuckle head if he has nothing in his favor but his
rank.
And that's,
that's it for this book.
And I think that closing statement,
okay,
don't be a chucklehead,
don't be a chocolate.
And this is just talked about earlier that they will follow the lowest man,
the lowest making ranking man present if he knows what he's doing and is the as
morally the master of the situation and can give a clear,
intelligent order.
And I think the rest of the,
you know,
if you're a chuckle head,
people aren't going to listen to you just because of your rank.
And I talk about that all the time.
You shouldn't use your rank.
Okay.
And
I think this book actually,
you know,
give some pretty,
some pretty obvious ways to avoid being a chuckle head.
Gee,
humble,
be calm,
educate yourself.
Okay.
Workout hard,
physical physicality is important.
It's all the stuff.
Same stuff that we talk about all the time.
And again,
these are universal and I know we've got a lot of listeners that are overseas.
This stuff was this,
it's applying to Americans for this applies basically a worldwide.
Yeah.
At least Western world.
And they've stood the test of time.
They work today,
so fall on them
and,
and lead this lead in everything you do is start by leading yourself with these
principles.
Because if you can't,
there's no way that you can lead others
if you can't lead yourself.
And I'll tell you where little over the three hour mark right now.
So it doesn't look like we're going to be doing Q and a this episode.
So if anyone is out there still listening at this point and they want to know
how to support the podcast Echo,
tell them how to do it well,
there's a few ways.
Yeah.
So let's start with the,
a lot of times I feel like it's just like kind of repetitive.
Well it is repetitive.
Yeah.
And since we've already had people listening for three plus hours at this point
we can feel free to move quickly,
I think.
Yeah,
I think so.
But here's the thing though.
Oh,
there's a,
but I did.
Yeah.
I did more thinking where,
what if this is the first time somebody was listening or maybe the second time
it won't be as repetitive.
Okay.
But if it's a person that they're going to listen to other ones,
sure.
To go back.
Yup.
And they can listen to one of those episodes.
That's an hour and a half and they going to be like,
oh,
I'm going to listen to a little bit more.
But right now if we go long right now,
yeah.
They may not listen at all.
Yeah.
Now some people say,
well,
we do.
It's fun.
We liked that.
No,
no.
Nothing is fun after three hours long and there's so much good information in
this book though.
I went long.
I'm sorry,
but I'm not really sorry.
There's good information.
Yeah,
that's the game.
It's good.
But I think we could proceed quickly.
That's what I think.
Sure.
I dig it.
That same,
no banter.
You know,
I know you've got things you want to talk about him with this stuff,
but avoid
the banter.
The key here is really the,
okay,
look,
I can,
okay,
we'll go ahead.
We'll go into it on it.
Supplementation,
you know,
sometime sometimes,
hey,
I don't need supplements,
I have a great diet or I'm just not into it.
Just in general.
I have to successfully conveyed the importance of supplementation or at the very
least the value.
Go ahead,
do it.
So I'm not going to banter with you.
I'm just going to go ahead and get after it right here as far as weight cause
you can anyway.
All right,
Chaka real quick on it.
Supplements,
if you didn't already know Krill oil or EDC k our EDC,
everyday consumption of supplements,
essential Krill oil for your joints and this is good because the legit one,
it's not the one where they kill a bunch of Krill,
grind them up and then sell it to you.
It's like a goose.
She's the real deal.
That helps you.
I can tell you the story about how it helped me,
but listen to the other 52 podcasts if you want to hear that story.
Yeah.
Just so I understand if you're going for results on it.
Supplements,
Krill oil,
EDC,
Alpha brain,
shroom tech.
Where are your bars?
Even though those aren't really supplements,
they're like,
but you do eat them every day.
Yeah,
everyday consumption.
And I got the uh,
the preworkout good.
I'm going to give it a shot and non stimulant by the way.
So you're not jittery.
Jittery.
Yeah.
Nothing like this.
And it's um,
it's like there's like earth grown ingredients in there as well.
Good.
It actually tastes good.
So audit calls,
things earth grown ingredients.
I'm just going to,
I know it sounds cool.
Where else are they growing space and wouldn't it be cooler if they grow space
or subterranean or something?
What's up?
Why are they trying to make it sound cool?
Good stuff.
How would they say that?
Well,
the answer has grown.
The answer to that is lab grown.
If you can grow stuff in the lab or just concoct it chemically and the lack
quiet.
So I'm just saying that's the differentiator.
You went,
which is good.
You went earth grown is actually cool.
It's a good thing.
And,
and if there's any more questions about these types of growth.
I was thinking,
I was thinking moon base alpha.
Yeah.
And if you can indicate the benefits of anything mooned grown,
I'm sure that they would provide that on the website or whatever.
That's where I get it.
The information anywhere Alpha brain is proven as well.
That's the thing with nootropics.
Nootropics,
which help your brain.
A lot of times people will be like,
Eh,
it's a placebo thing.
They went through the real test to prove that it works.
Proven scientifically fact that it's dope.
Anyway,
on a.com/chocolate get 10% off.
If you want 10% off,
if you don't want 10% off,
just go on it.com paypal price,
boom,
support everybody,
everything,
whatever,
whatever.
No,
you're actually not supporting anybody and you're definitely not supporting us.
If you don't do that.
That's cool.
We'll technically it is cause it's like you're still getting your supplements.
You know,
you're still getting supplementation.
We're just not getting the credit.
So just like if like you donate to a cause and you put anonymous in the thing
and then you donate another 10% same thing.
See what I'm saying?
Anyway,
I'm going to just let this one go and that's a good way because I realized I'm
guilty for making these things longer cause I'm interjecting.
Yeah,
I should just be quiet.
Be Quiet.
What's your podcast?
So you say whatever you like.
Our podcast,
come on.
So on it is one of the ways to support to wrap it up on.com/jocko get 10% off.
Help hates they're good.
Just trust me.
They're good.
Another good way.
Christmas is almost here,
man.
It's like what?
For three,
four days,
something like that.
So I'm like that.
If you shop in Amazon,
click through the website.
That's a good way to support.
Click through the website.
That's called
Jocko store.com or called Jocko podcast.com
that's the website you got to click through,
correct?
Yes.
Jocko,
podcast.com over on the side,
there's the Amazon little banner.
Click on that one before he damaged Amazon shopping for Christmas or whatever,
or buying any one of these books that that Jocko talks about on the Jocko story.
You got to go on the menu items support and then it'll take you to the page with
the band.
Hey,
speaking of which,
a podcast,
100 as we talked about when Tim was on this podcast,
Tim Ferriss was on this podcast.
We're going to do Musashi for podcast 100 because it's a big,
big,
big book.
Oh right.
You mentioned that we need to get it on the Po,
so that will be on the website.
So you can buy that book now cause it's a thick book and when to do it for
podcast 100 right.
You can click through.
The other thing is that's beneficial about these ways of supporting the podcast.
No advertisements on the podcast except for this here,
which I guess could be considered an advertisement,
but I don't want to have the,
and now for a commercial break.
Yeah,
we would like to present.
Yeah.
Something that doesn't matter.
Are you tired of sleeping right?
You know,
that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
So yeah,
the Amazon please.
That's a good one.
That's like,
um,
cause it doesn't cost them nothing.
It's like super easy and it's like you're kind of just in the whole game of
just,
you know,
reinforcements,
support,
Amazon,
click through the website before you do shopping,
boom.
You can also subscribe to the podcast.
I know that seems obvious,
but sometimes you don't.
Back to this,
you know,
you talk about this sometimes Amazon,
so you can click through Amazon,
right?
Let's say you're going to buy something that's not expensive,
like a,
like a bunch of pins.
Sure.
Or some duct tape.
You might think,
aw man,
I'm just going to go directly to Amazon because that's no big deal.
Right?
We don't need to support the podcast on this purchase.
There's two problems with that.
Number one,
if no one bought their duct tape without clicking through,
we wouldn't get any of the benefit of having the site there.
The other thing is you've got an extra exercise,
daily discipline in all things and that if you get,
my point is that if you get in the habit of doing it,
then you'll be in the habit.
Otherwise if you only do it sometimes,
then the time you go out and buy a lawn mower then you know,
or something,
somebody bought a set of golf clubs.
Remember that guy say he's like,
I just bought some ball golf course,
like thousand dollars set of golf clubs,
clubs he clicked through,
you know,
so that,
that definitely supports the podcast.
But it's because he had the discipline,
the reinforced reiteration of doing it all the time.
So just do it.
Just do it all the time.
That's my recommendation.
Yeah it is true man.
Cause that's kind of the key is to remember to do and here's the end and
everyone's duck tape counts and,
and here's the thing,
like you're under no obligation to do that.
I'm just saying,
most times you'd be like,
Hey,
I want to support the podcast.
It's cool because you
know,
but at the time of,
you know,
hey,
I need my duct tape,
I go and do it.
I buy the duct tape and it's like,
oh,
I forgot.
You know,
just to kind of avoid that kind of situation.
If you have any in your mind,
that's really the key is to remember that then you're living with the guilt
barely can go on anyway.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I'll do that or subscribe to the podcast or end subscribe to the podcast I
should say.
Yup.
It seems obvious on iTunes he subscribed,
but I don't know if you haven't already subscribed,
that's a good way to support and leave a review man.
If,
if you're compelled to,
those reviews are pretty dope by the way.
I'm subscribed on Youtube.
We are along with the podcasts in video format.
We'll do some excerpts stuff you can share with people that they don't,
they don't have to commit to three hours and you know,
however long the case may be to listen to the whole podcast thing and just
listen to the,
you know,
three minute,
one minute,
five minute even.
You know,
things about whatever the case may be,
but whatever little excerpts,
you know,
um,
I think those are beneficial.
I think when people share that time with me,
I think you can learn a lot.
For sure.
I think there's a lot to be said for it.
I think I agree with you.
Or we have store,
Jocko has a store,
it's called now you say,
I have a store.
We have a store.
Not My store.
Yeah,
but if I say Jocko has a store,
it's called Jocko store.
Okay.
It just sounds kind of cooler.
Okay,
so let's find a regional name too.
Yeah.
So I was trying to do that,
but kind of interrupted.
But that's cool.
There's some cool shirts on there,
some layers on the shirts and we'll let you look.
You see the layers on your own,
soGood@jockostore.com.
See if he can find the layers on the shirt.
I'm not saying to buy a shirt or a tank top or a Hoodie or forest.
I'm not saying to buy one,
but if you feel compelled to buy one because you think they're cool,
the layers hit you,
they resonate with you.
I don't like that word resonate.
You use it anyway.
If they resonate with you,
get a shirt.
That's a good way to support
some patches too.
Do you know the,
the ones that with the Velcro,
this regulation,
those are on there too.
Yup.
Per your and other people's requests.
We had a lot of military and law enforcement that wanted regulation size.
Yeah.
Second one.
Color in the field as has a crushing evil in the world.
Yeah man.
So yeah,
they're on there too and whatever else.
Uh,
you know,
you think is cool where I'm going to Redo the mugs,
they're going to be like the,
like a special like one,
like a super high quality one.
The travel mugs.
Yeah.
The,
Yep.
And then,
um,
yeah,
there you go.
And,
and um,
psychological warfare.
See that was a done that turned out good.
And I'm going to tell you that I was listening to your explanation of what
psychological warfare was you to listen to it.
It
is unclear you,
you,
you told the story,
but it was like,
you know,
we're talking to each other right now.
Yeah.
And you were telling me,
you're kind of telling me the story,
right?
But I know a bunch about it.
So when I listened to it,
I said,
you know what,
people that are aren't that,
don't know what this is are going to wonder what this is.
Echo asked me some questions about what I'm thinking about in certain situations
of weakness,
right?
Certain situations of weaknesses.
And he asked me a couple of minutes and I kind of told them like off the cuff,
oh I pick about this and this.
And he's kind of got that look in his face when I know he's thinking of
something.
So I said,
oh,
he's thinking of something.
And then the next day,
you know,
hey,
we got to do record these.
So he,
we came up with some more questions that echo is like,
oh,
this is a good one.
This is a good one.
Came up with the questions and then I wrote down the answers and I read them
into a microphone.
We recorded it because that's what what eco does.
And then he said,
hey,
I'm going to make this into,
cause people ask for ringtones.
They give,
they want to be able to awake to,
cause they want to be able to wake to me alarm clocks and stuff.
So He's,
I'm going to put these on iTunes and put them for sale.
And I said,
oh well if that's what you think.
So the album is called s so it's an album of clips there like two or three
minutes long.
You know,
they're for,
they're for cub there for psychological warfare against moments of weakness.
And we're into the mode one once a weakness come when you want to get up in the
morning.
So there's,
there's actually,
cause I know that's a hard one for people.
There's three psychological attacks against the weakness of not getting out of
bed in the morning.
There's psychological warfare against wanting to eat bad food.
There's psychological warrant warfare against procrastination.
Just moments of weakness are covered in the psychological warfare album.
Very well covered.
And it's for sale on iTunes and you,
you got to search for w Jocko Willink or psychological warfare.
It's a little bit hard to find because of the way I tunes is laid out because
it's in spoken word,
but that doesn't drop down under music anyways.
It's kind of hard to find,
but it is on there and it's for sale.
And that is in fact another way to support the podcast because it is for sale
because people want to support the podcast.
And so they say,
hey,
you know,
how can we support the podcast and the,
we used to say,
people say,
Oh,
do you have this thing where you can donate money if it will just give you
money.
I don't want you to just to give me money when to give you something if you,
you,
you just don't give me money,
I'm not going to take it.
Well,
well there's been to public a couple people that have given money,
which is awesome.
We appreciate it.
But for the general,
for,
for my general a conscience,
right?
Right.
Reciprocation.
I want to give you something back.
So here's what we give you.
You give us money for the iTunes album,
you get something back and you know what?
You get back discipline in MP three format.
That's what you get.
So check it out.
They're
pretty,
they're,
they're funny either no screaming,
but they're,
they're getting after it in the feedback that I've gotten was awesome.
Like everyone's done Twitter zoo.
I bid out of bed.
Every time you I overeat know I didn't procrastinate on this project and the
debit.
Debbie said,
oh,
I got this project done a week early because I didn't want to procrastinate.
But two,
two side notes to that one.
If you're going to do the alarm clock thing,
he said this last time,
clear it with your,
whoever you're sleeping with,
your wife or whatever,
just make sure that they have the heads up because if they hear it,
they're going to flip out.
Yeah.
And they won't flip out because I'm going crazy.
They'll flip out because all of a sudden there's a man in the room talking and
that's enough nice.
The fruit.
Somebody okay,
you got one.
Yeah.
So kind of go over it.
You know,
go over the plan.
You don't want to freak people out.
You having,
you're having your significant other were reaching for their sidearm.
Yeah.
Putting the laser on around the room.
Searching and a second side note.
Good feedback for sure.
But it's been,
I look at the stats sometimes it's been number one and spoken word category on
iTunes.
Number one.
That's fine.
There's some other good people on that list,
but it's not,
it's been number one for,
that's awesome.
Since I put we put it on there.
Dang.
Anyway.
Well thank you everyone.
That's everyone that's leading.
Yeah.
Everyone that's,
that's picking that up.
Thank you.
Appreciate that.
That's awesome.
But yeah,
those are a gas solid ways to support.
A couple of other ways that you can support this.
One is you can get some Jocko white tea.
It's pomegranate white tea.
This on pomegranate.
Granted there can get some of that stuff.
If you haven't gotten it and you think,
I don't like tea,
you're wrong because you haven't tried this tea cause it tastes,
it doesn't take,
I'm telling you it doesn't taste,
I don't know what it tastes like.
You know what it tastes like.
It tastes like what it tastes like.
There's nothing else that you can compare it to.
It just tastes good,
really good and it's got a little bit of caffeine in it.
You can actually drink it before you go to bed if you need to.
You won't and won't keep you up.
It's not that kind of caffeine.
Is there different guys,
a couple of other kinds of earth grown caffeine.
It's gets kind of caffeine that there's not a lot in there.
It's got,
it's got antioxidants in there and it tastes really good and you can have it pre
workout,
post workout,
pre meal post-meal pre bed after bed,
during bed.
You can get her to have it whenever you want.
So that's the Jocko white tea.
You can get that and by the way,
it's now been in stock.
I'm going on like three or four or five days.
It's in stock now.
We've got a better system.
We might have another fade.
I got some stuff on the horizon.
There might be a little little dip in the system,
but it's in stock in the,
in the tin.
The luxurious tin luxury or the big box,
which has a hundred in it.
Reload,
reload,
and then you can get a mug.
You can get a mug.
By the way,
the Mug,
it'll tell you what to do.
It'll tell you what to do every single time and will tell you to do is get after
it.
You know?
Did you get that Mug on
there?
Jocko proofed and then extreme ownership.
The book Christmas.
Why not get it for every single person you've ever known in your life,
you might as well know,
uh,
extreme ownership.
If you listen to the podcast and you kind of like what we talk about here,
the book extreme ownership,
it's about the same thing.
It's about combat leadership.
Also,
speaking of extreme ownership,
again,
New York City,
May 4th and fifth,
we're doing the extreme ownership muster.
Number zero zero two the last one was zero zero one in San Diego,
this one zero zero to May 4th and fifth at the Marriott.
We're going deep on combat leadership,
which means we're going deep on all leadership because the principals do not
change the thing.
That's cool.
Everybody that's there,
everyone's in the game.
Everyone's in the game.
Ceos,
mid level managers,
every industry you can think of and life's going to be their echoes going to be
there.
P is going to be there in the game with you.
You know,
we're not hiding behind the curtain,
we're not backstage.
We'll be interacting,
hanging out,
doing what have we got to do and I'm telling you it's gonna sell out.
So register a s a p I know that echo is going to make some videos and the videos
that he's gonna make are going to show the last muster and as soon as those
videos come out,
it's going to sell out because I've already seen the footage.
It looks awesome.
It is awesome.
It was awesome.
And the next one is going to be awesome.
So,
so join now.
Register now.
There's discounted tickets if you're law enforcement,
firefighters or military,
we got discounted tick tickets if you want to ask questions or get that
discount.
Also,
if you have like 10 12 people coming from,
you're coming from your company,
we can get a discount going there too.
You can email muster@echelonfront.com you can also check out the website,
extreme ownership.com real original.
We thought of that one and we look forward to seeing you guys there in the
meantime.
Okay.
If,
if you want to kind of kick it with us,
we are kicking it ourselves on the Inter webs on Twitter,
on Instagram as well.
And also we got to be on that one,
that Facebook ball,
how are we going to be,
their
echo is at Echo Charles and I m at Jocko Willink and finally
go out there.
Yeah,
and execute.
And we talk a lot about a lot of different subjects on this podcast and we hear
from incredible leaders in the lessons that we learned today,
lessons that were learned and lessons that are written in blood.
But those lessons are meaningless.
They're meaningless if you don't execute on them.
If you listen without doing,
you might as well not even waste your time.
Just keep being arrogant and wasting your time not being productive and not
living up to your potential to keep wasting your life if you're not going to
execute on what we learned.
But if you listen
and then you go and you do than stay on it.
And remember also that the rewards don't come easy.
Don't count on any glory.
Just hold the line.
Great.
And stay on the path so that you know,
so that you know that you are in the game 100%
and that you know that you
are getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.